are we live huh I think you know how it
goes welcome well we do we need
confirmation first yeah all it takes is
one person to this is engaged say you
can hear us and I guarantee you we will
just move along smoothly from here on
out yeah
smooth sailin as the Queens of the Stone
Age yes or a lot of people oh man we got
all the cedra gators there watch amid
some Marv with his mother yeah Ronnie
that's not a movie I don't know actually
it depends what do you mean it it's so
hard to describe I can imagine that if
you have a mom who's really into like
freaky genre stuff you know it's it's
not the same to me as like watching like
a raunchy movie with like I feel like
midsummer you could still have some kind
of film appreciation about that's fair
but well guys thank you guys so much for
being here what's up we got so many
people in the chat Anisa obviously Biff
Tannen Xander Miller Gabriel Mimi and
flightless Skippy are BLL y'all so many
names a name two names to name right now
but we'll be going through the chat as
we do this was ina pop-tarts commercial
so today's theme with the honor of
Mother's Day as movies you regret
watching with your family now these can
be movies that just made you
uncomfortable in terms of the experience
that you have but we just want to hear
whatever you guys got I'm assuming these
will be like you know it all depends I
think I have movies that I already
coming in mind for me that we're like
you know when I was a little kid two
movies I watched as an adult it doesn't
matter what age they can still be
uncomfortable unless you're a bunch of
freaks in your family through what's
you're a bunch of freaks oh we already
got a hey Andy so it's up thank you
right okay so right on cue she wants to
be number one
contributor and the livestreams as
always hello my lovely people I watched
the entire 50 shades oh my god no my mom
yes super awkward at some points oh I
forgot to mention to John for everyone
who's super chats a day he's gonna do in
his mark Whalberg voice say hi to your
mother for me so John please tell Anissa
hey Nisa say hi to your mother for me
Donnie Donnie that may come a time oh I
can't imagine watching 50 shades with
the family member I get uncomfortable if
if I'm with my girlfriend I'm getting
turned on watching something like that
so you got a [ __ ] boner you pervert
I'm like yeah you take it out on me and
she'll say something funny the V knocker
movie so guys thank you and ISA start
telling us the movies in the comments
below we just go through them as we you
know what a really awkward was for me
what year did it come out John yes what
year could Brokeback Mountain come out
oh man
2008 2005 oh so I saw Brokeback Mountain
with my mom and the theater was packed
so we're at the very like front row
where you're looking up at the screen
like that oh yeah I heard you know as a
gay romance movie whatever 15 years old
things got very uncomfortable for me
when they like they're making out you're
like okay that's expected they're bound
to make out right but then all the
sudden Heath Ledger just turns over Jake
Gyllenhaal starts ramming him in the bud
up there my mom's right next to me this
this is not sweet really hardcore
intense gay action right not wholesome
yeah that was very uncomfortable but it
is progressive John well I'm going
through these what else do you got I
will never forget this wasn't the most
like the
the most uncomfortable but it was a
situation where I sat through a movie
with my dad and I was like this is not
the movie we should have come see
together and I really appreciate him for
having taken me and also having sat
through the entire thing we watched saw
two in the theaters and it was my first
saw movie oddly enough and I was just
like you have heard this good horror
movie I really want to see it
and once we walked out my dad was like
not gonna lie to you I hated that and
and all the way through like I still
enjoyed the movie obvious I'm huge Soph
and so it must have worked but yeah I
was very uncomfortable about you know a
quarter of my body you know that whole
time being like I don't blame you man
I'd be uncomfortable with my mom today
to watch saw yeah definitely imagine you
remember I watched porn with your mom
yeah she's a connoisseur she's very open
mind she would never watch porn with
John but she watched porn with me
terrible mom skills I know my mom would
constantly watch my mom would watch porn
you know what one time I it was weird or
this story I have seen some I've gone to
movies with my mom on occasion that you
know you aren't your typical going to
the movies with mom movies and and I
remember this is one that almost wound
up as a regret until like the punch line
came in which is we were both really
into Chappelle's Show and we rented
half-baked just because we're like what
if spell she's funny well watch this
movie didn't realize it was a stoner
comedy all about you know we didn't stop
and especially when I was like 12 or 13
I sat through that movie and there's
like mild nudity too so I was weird and
then afterwards though there was like an
awkward silence and then we agreed that
it was a funny movie and since then
we've we've put it on TV again so I
thought it would be this but it was I
suppose that's awkward
I can imagine I mean yeah I feel like
most people are wrong in her name movies
like I didn't broke Batman movies they
were like sexual based well yeah yeah
that's usually the most awkward
especially in America there's there's
another one but I'll save it for
recession because okay so in the chat we
got red Sparrow oh that would be awkward
with your family although we might be
able to Lampoon it or something
showgirls yeah I I watched showgirls
when I was like six years old but I
didn't watch it my dad my dad got a VHS
copy of showgirls and I popped it in the
video tape machine when I was young
though IIIi did watch scream with them
violence was never really that
uncomfortable for me but I did watch
monsters ball with my brother and my dad
my dad was they had like a sheet on the
ground and they were just like lay down
on the living room floor and watch
movies and I was on the couch and then
when Halle Berry and Billy Bob started
going at it my dad doesn't even get up
and turns TV off or lower it he just
puts his hand up over my face like that
he's watching it I'm behind he just goes
it's just like what's happen ooh
Carter Lovejoy thank you dude Thank You
Carter
John say hi to your mother for me you
could at least cap it off with a comma
Carter hey Carter there you go
is this your thing okay I like your
comment it's really awkward Washington
pulp fiction with your family I agree hi
to your mother for me I watched Pulp
Fiction with my mom a year or two ago
and she walked out when it got to the
[ __ ] scene you know oh never mind I got
lucky with that because my parents are
super into I love you with that because
the first time I watched it it was in
the living room and my family was there
but they all had seen it before so
[ __ ] bizarre I was watching and they
they fell asleep yeah so it's still a
very uncomfortable [ __ ] scene all that
stuff was very uncomfortable for me just
a why do bras by myself
but fortunately they were asleep so I
didn't have to endure
that experience with them boy we got
someone here saying Django Unchained
yeah that's an awkward one for sure
oddly enough I saw that in the theaters
my dad and had a blast
oh yeah well he had that advisor Django
yeah he knows the struggle get those
flavors
we're both Sykes and Hilary B thank you
for saying that happy Mother's Day to
everyone absolutely everyone's mothers
Jenna Jenna Jenna I have a special
request for this one Jen's really close
to their dad so can you say say hi to
your father for me hey Jenna appreciate
the Jenna it's really nice you okay
really appreciate the super chat daddy
father Thank You Jenna that's really
sweet of you
hey guys I love you all very much well I
love yet oh and I just started working
at jo-ann fabrics and just started in
the middle of copán that's fascinating I
survived my first week I hope you keep
on surviving I don't really regret
watching anything I'm just like me
that's fair
I mean maybe your parents looked after
you or maybe you're just not into the
kind of movies that that would be
awkward to Montee at home exactly so if
anything I'm happy for you that's a big
sigh of relief actually Thank You Jenna
that's so thank you congratulations on
your new job I know so many people who
swear by and worship the jo-ann fabrics
so actually my I have a family member
who was fired from jo-ann fabrics so did
you take you know what we can talk about
that later we can talk about that later
Tony vich thanks Josh you rock oh we got
a guy blockers watching super rad with
your family which I think may have
almost I think I may have seen a good
chunk of super bad with my family and
that was awkward I mean like there are
families I've met that really love
vulgar humor together of things yes guy
named Jared that we used to know and
they loved like really rot but
were also they were like a real I say
hippie family that yeah they're like
real like hippie kind of family I heard
stories he was the dad just walk around
naked and give a [ __ ] they were they're
like sexually open hairy kind of family
I don't really count have is a Netflix
category waiting someone saying
transformers 2 with that what would that
be uncommon watch I just regret the
movie experience and of itself Hillary
Clinton Miller clowns from outer space
that's the beaver version where a
lobster mmm
trying to keep up with the chat here
Bohemian Rhapsody why is that be
uncomfortable for you to watch you know
mom's a big Bryan Singer fan that's fair
oh I am Ninja Panda sorry where we are
yeah you are thank you I am ninja panda
hey ninja Panda say hi to your mother
for me happy Mother's Day ninja panda
it's good to see you I regret watching
the context of the film were exist is
this your family like a pain in the ass
though I don't know how to pick do they
not shut the [ __ ] up when you're
watching a movie because that can be
really annoying with the family you're
like I want to show you the Irishman
stop talking I don't want McDonald's
right now mom because my family was not
too into the Irish know that I watched
it with my family so I don't miss that
then the whole Thai know you
I don't regret watching it with them
that was one of those experiences where
I was like the only one in this room
like in this movie yeah more than not
you know what movie I saw with my mom I
really hope my mom is why this is the
first last room I hope she's watching so
chic here all that porn talk it was that
my mom yeah I must have been 15 taking
lives Oh
with Angelina Jolie Epton Haga seen that
movie no I remember watching the trailer
with David though we talked eNOS we saw
taking lives and there is a real
Genet intense sex scene between Angelina
Jolie and Ethan Hawke in that movie and
it's uncomfortable especially when
you're getting into the sexy but your
mom's right there eating her pop and my
mom's allowed popcorn eater like it's
the point were like can you reserve
eating the popcorn when there's a car
chance go easy it's hard when she stops
eating the popcorn turn the sexy Thank
You I'm in Japan de hereditary we got
someone saying in a king is are saying
hereditary yeah Sully's an interesting
job I was max a solid we're I'm also a
pilot and I've done some questionable
things behind the wheels my mom kept
hoping that the plane would crash oh and
yes rest in peace to Little Richard rest
in peace have been got a lot more soul
going up there now anis is back Anissa
Anissa say hello again for me to your
mother you know I think it needs so with
him if if you agree to sleep with Anissa
and if you had one condition which is
your mom has to be in the room I think
Anissa would agree to it that's how much
she's into you John lip with the
verification when I saw any movie with
all boom boom time scene with my mom
wait is boom boom assuming that is that
I mean gun action to she always made me
close my eyes every single time lol John
House censored were you I don't know
John how was sneaking an episode of The
Simpsons in when you were younger get
probably more intense feeling than it
should have
it was pretty easy in hindsight know how
to quantify like I wasn't allowed to
watch a ton of very explicit rate our
movies but I would often be privy to
like if they knew the movie well enough
they would just cover my eyes for the
sex or anything too gory
I was kind of how that went by they
always let me watch gore my family did
not care sex was like like I mean was a
Catholic household so for some reason
you know like violence is alright but
sex was very taboo mm-hm
but even then sometimes I didn't really
give two shits there was like a boob on
screen or whatever they didn't care but
if it got like oh this is getting really
intense you should send me out of the
room don't just don't just be like look
the other way
cuz I can easily look at find a million
angles to use my peripheral vision I saw
species and the feeders of my dad
talking about boom boom time scene and
this Anisa species is a movie about oh
an alien who looks like a model and
she's trying stars natasha Henstridge
and she's trying to impregnate herself
so she's just like having sex with all
it's actually a really intense movie but
she's sleeping with all these people in
the hopes of getting pregnant and yeah
there's some graphic sex and sex scenes
and nudity in that movie and ya saw that
with them so my dad a couple times why
but he did censor me whenever that talk
there's a moment where she like gets
really aggressive with her tongue and
then the tongue shoots out at the back
of a guy's neck my dad made sure not
that's what I mean all this all the
nudity fine whatever
for some reason with that violent moment
like too much too much to handle at that
what did he really want to see it again
why did you go why did he go with you
twice today I really liked the movie
clearly he didn't feel awkward about it
toys toys say my parents really didn't
care the movies they took us I remember
watching Titanic in the theatres with my
parents when I was 10 my brother was 8
and watching Rose Gaines sketch was very
weird
oh I tannic is an interesting one
because Titanic that's I like that come
on a lot toy because Titanic was a one
of the biggest movies of all time so
most people have seen it and a lot of
families went to go watch it and there's
a very famous painting and a naked woman
seen in that film and so was that like a
error exception during the time we're
like yeah it's tight it's [ __ ]
Titanic its let him watch the let's see
roses boobs you know I mean I guess if I
was if I was a parent in the context if
it's just like nudity and it's not about
sex perhaps I don't know it's the human
form whatever is sketching her or maybe
that's suggestive but like I can
understand the argument I guess cuz I
don't know I do think that we should
maybe be a little more chill about like
the concept of nudity and more look at
the context of the nudity but yeah we
got are you listening yet saying the
never got my eyes cover when nutri
sexual scenes it was just awkward
silence I hate you know how
uncomfortable was I actually okay I
never got my eyes cover when neuter
sexual scenes it was just awkward
silence and I hated how uncomfortable it
was you know I actually feel like that
would be worse in some ways mm-hmm
because at least you have something to
think about with your eyes over your a
hand over your eyes like what's going on
out of my face yeah at least there's
something being acknowledged I think on
acknowledgement can be a lot more of an
uncomfortable moment in time see that's
what happens now when there's like a
raunchy sex scene or some kind of Rod
cheap piece of humor is just it it lands
with a thud it masses nobody comments on
it and we go huh oh man and pool you
know there was a sex montage and
Deadpool would be very fun to the family
that's one of those movies where I don't
think any of my I know my sister I think
saw it but I don't know if my mom or dad
have and I feel like that's a movie I
Teeter on the edge with because I'm like
I think she would enjoy some stuff about
this a lot there's some stuff I think
would be a little hard to explain away
or not explain but you know be like I
didn't need to see you know so a lot of
people are naming horror movies for sure
in this chat you know Friday the 13th
remake with your family Robert is saying
sausage party particularly that last
scene yeah who's your family
you know would you know what makes me
more uncomfortable actually more so than
with my parents ISM is my my younger
sister and my younger sister only she's
only six years younger than me but even
to this day I remember we this is
several years ago obviously but we saw
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo together
in the theatres and that was very
uncomfortable for me to watch them I
would like do this with my sister in the
room oh yeah yeah leave you who my
younger self it's like of course she
knows about sex that's when my brother
[ __ ] comes out of me watch it's a pure
world so my Catholic boy bringing me kka
comes into play Anisa back in the chat
here whoa number three say hi to your
mother thrice for me off topic here
thank you and ISA off topic here but did
you know that Chris Evans told his mom
when he lost his virginity right after
it happened let's say he was very open
with his mom uh I mean I could see a
scenario where that makes sense if you
have a very sex positive household I
mean I wouldn't my mom still thinks I'm
and she's walking on me still I think it
just depends it's like what's Chris
Evans like they have a single his mom a
single mom was a dad in the picture
sometimes that clothes bonk and can do
it you know I just don't think Chris
Evans can do any wrong he's captain [ __ ]
in America or right if he wants to tell
his mom about orgies and stuff that he
has let him tell his mom that he does
and if he's that open with his mom the
probably House of being like a more of a
vulnerable actor to if you have that
close of a relationship with your mom
yeah I don't know I'm spitballing here
I'm not a [ __ ] talented actress I was
thinking that it might be part of it
yeah I mean he told her the first time
you probably tells her every time he
bangs a girl it's a little photo selfie
living the good life mom look what babe
got me mom
yes we're all sad venom 2 was postponed
Thank You Austin yeah
Satre that spiral was postponed Oh
random Andy's channel random Andy see I
do your mother for me
Thank You random Andy's Channel god I
love this look that he has it's a real
freaking who's the guy in serenity
Oh Nathan feeling yeah he's got a real
nathan fillion meets Johnny Bravo thing
yeah the shadows in the contrast is very
moody I have a huge love for the film
dirty dancing my parents are not big on
unclean dancing and I was wasn't
thinking when we sat down and watch it
they gave me looks whenever there was
those two seats really wow house how
uncomfortable of a family household must
have been for you growing up I feel like
a lot of these comments can be very
insightful yeah into the kind of like
just dancing sturdy I mean the dirty
dance scene from what I recall I feel
like Save the Last Dance had more
intense dance scenes than Dirty Dancing
did because that's like flat-out
grinding on someone's ass or Flashdance
where she's like just in her underwear
and sweating her ass off and dancing
like that to me is very erotic but I
mean already dancing is just passionate
dancing and I don't know how to dirty
dance well in the film dirty dish that
what you'd call dirty dance like dirty
dancing by yeah by like this generation
standards is like the bump and grind you
know which I feel like dirty dancing as
a movie definitely has to passion but
it's like it's one of those that broke
the ground for its time you know I was
such a [ __ ] when it came to dancing
when like grinding was coming around
that I would run the other way yeah like
start occurring in like sixth grade when
that's what the new norm of the kind of
dancing it was to me it wasn't real
dancing just a girl grinding her her ass
on your crotch I didn't get comfortable
the thought to like around eighth-grade
time I was always having like my
justifications for why grinding wasn't
written when really I was just scared to
do the kind of dancing it was well yeah
because it's it's a
it's a lot more than you think it is
it's intimate there are things to worry
about you know it takes a minute to get
used to that well I also thought like
some people grind but then there are
also people I was hearing about that
would get uncomfortable if a guy got a
boner and I was like well then this is
really a conflicted situation I mean
right and what if you didn't would that
be insulting that's a great comment
below I do you know Brazil's in South
America what El Salvador Venezuela hey
Jake you've seen um Ontario Canada here
Oh Justin Martelli and Mike matino is
saying Borat
oh ho you know I saw that in the
theaters my family and went over okay
I can imagine Borat being a very
uncomfortable expect I would be
uncomfortable my family hated like the
kind of humor I like they they hated
like crude and vulgar humor still do to
this day and so what you're they
wouldn't laugh once during Borat I know
they wouldn't and that scene came up the
change Channel no that would not
happened yeah
Casino Royale torture scene that said
that's the decent cause good call now
I'm calling James as balls for the world
what else do we got daniel Jones hey
happy early birthday daniel Jones geared
toward zinc geared towards equality
Monde instagrams right in shoes you and
me still gotta have a FaceTime date bro
I don't know why but my mother made me
watch what meant what men want you love
other scenario it's not is a lot of
these situations are I joined my parents
on this new movie or I introduced them
and I was a bad idea and this was my mom
wanted why was it why was it awkward
though it was it because it was like not
a good movie and you felt strange in
there or was it like it seems like I had
the potential to be pretty raunchy I
mean watching what woman while my mom
was a major Mel Gibson fan growing up my
love for Mel Gibson's stamp I'm bringing
this up because what men want is to
write from the what woman want plot um
and I and I'm watching what woman want
made me very uncomfortable my mom like
Mel Gibson when Helen Hunt's like oh my
god just goes crotch you know like that
makes me very uncomfortable but the the
[ __ ] was a talk I just saw one see
someone in the chat say Heath Ledger
ramming and I was like what's he talking
but I was I found out just yesterday
just yesterday my mom has given up on
Mel Gibson well I will not give up on
Mel mom I will not
did you have any Mother's Day happy
Mother's Day
well I want to see her tomorrow cuz his
mother's day and i was like what Mel
Gibson movie should I put on in the
background she's like I don't and then I
mean even asked her like oh my god have
you have you turned the other cheek John
make sure to text back geared towards
ink man I'm gonna DJ text back as soon
as you can I gotta you I mean we got
both gotta send them some sizes
apparently I mean if I have my size you
should yeah I think you means shirt
though right I don't know gizelle whose
face is fabric you let me know which one
you're talking about
hmm okay then how about finding a movie
of your parents yeah no oh man with them
in the room does that mean yeah I would
regret that anyway but yeah well Timmy
turtle one is saying how about finding
movie your parents like a sex type of
your parents exactly or what would be
more awkward a sex type of your parents
or a full-length feature film
independently produce that they were
hoping to star in and become major
successes and it's just so cringe-worthy
because of the terrible acting and
performances oh I guess I would be sad
about that first be sadder because the
sex tape at least is like a sign of joys
we're we're good we got a record you
ggtort evie jeang say hi to your mother
for me I showed my mom Thank You Jean I
show my mama my niece the Japanese
newbee grotesque why it wasn't a regret
of funny as hell what's grotesque
it'sit's a really extreme torture II
Japanese horror movie oh goodness I
think it's the one with the cover where
it's the open mouth with the bleeding
eyeball in it or something and your mom
was cool with you watching that yeah I
don't know I'm getting a scene is like
like Allah is like our age I imagine
maybe not now no I do a long time so you
know these days the choices are very
calculated because of like time and
everything though it's usually a movie
we would all be happy I'm more like just
just keep watching you're NCIS what's up
knees film 2009 yes it is this one hey
hey if you say love you guys and you're
a guy you don't need to back it up with
a no homo thing who'd you just block you
don't need no homo any more milk oh my
god what is them welcome is this second
live stream in a row and I still don't
know what the milk thing is Joaquin
doesn't want us to drink it and as usual
we have fallen behind on the super chats
because we were also going to the
regular comic event horizon with that I
guess it depends on how they feel about
intense you know body horror II say like
there's mesmerizing have like sexy it's
mostly like messed up I remember because
I know how how like cautionary hmm your
family can be with r-rated stuff growing
up and I remember your dad took us to
watch phone booth amount of [ __ ] in
that movie me and talking about [ __ ]
in that movie I was uncomfortable to be
just as your friend with it's a very so
man is this a test yeah that was very
uncomfortable talking about sex and like
masturbation and stuff like that in that
movie like there's a lie
okay so oh we got the pop culture I'm
sorry I can't show kids this song we
fell behind we're gonna learn OBS in the
next coming week so that way we can
properly showcase everyone who
contributes and the super test and thank
you to everyone who is the pop culture
crochet hmm my parents thank you by the
way
my parents were religious fundamentalist
so many were excruciating but the
standout was the 40 year old virgin
awkward as oh that may have been I may
have had an awkward experience watching
that with family I am right there with
you pop culture Cher I I took a gamble
on that one because like I said a few
minutes ago my parents hate crude humor
they don't like it
I grew up in a very like they were like
strict Catholics so the idea of like
that kind of sexual the chat would be
very unsettling right and I decided like
I thought the Florida version was
actually a really good movie and I was
like I gotta convince my dad to go watch
this would me I'm like you know I just
gotta get him to take a chance on this
one just get him to take a chance he got
to and then we went to the theaters of
course he paid for us he didn't want to
but he did like a kid and then we
watched the movie he didn't laugh once
he laughed when he was riding the bike
and he fell and that was it simple non
raunchy joke but he was like that was
funny but not one time in that two and a
half hour comedy did he actually laugh
at a like the big laugh moment yeah I
think that was awkward and I want to say
we maybe even tried to watch knocked up
and stops freely as a family yeah oh God
Kim Possible why why would that be
awkward John keep listen listen another
one I'm gonna fix this okay
well I mean one of
mine that is a classic John's story as I
truly and deeply regret as in
nine-year-old boy I think or an
eight-year-old boy pleading and begging
my parents to take me to see blade in
the theatres
what yeah as a little kid yeah it was
when it was out I I cut the poster out
of the LA Times calendar section and
hung it on my wall I wanted to see blade
so bad I had like other friends who've
seen it tell me about it so that like I
can tell them like okay there's not that
much swearing but you know there's no
sex but there's like violence I don't
know if I was even right but we went and
I remember the first scene feeling very
awkward even then because I I feel like
the opening scene there like in the car
together and she puts a hand on his
crotch or something and then they go
into this club and then the people and
they're clever dancing and grinding and
then someone takes like a boomerang
knife through the bottom of the head and
then we were leaving the theatre oh
goodness
and and yeah that was way so you guys
left the movie theater after like 10
minutes oh man oh yeah yeah still have
not seen blade to this day because of
that that was I'm so sorry it's okay
it's become a piece of my life a it's a
good movie I'm really conflicted I'm
like should I go back and watch it now
or should I keep this thing intact cuz
like will it will it be like will it be
a great movie to me now that it has this
like thing built up in my mind I'll just
be like a movie no man that's too bad I
know that's too bad
yeah blade Oh mm a king in the chat is
saying Austin Powers machine gun Jubilee
see that's what like when I said my
family very humor hated Austin Powers
and when I watched they rented it and
when I was watching it I would just by
myself going is the bathtub man again ah
he also gets in the hot tub with a girl
in the first one and then my dad looked
at me he's like I feel like the first to
Austin Powers I may have regretted
having seen around family but for
whatever reason we all enjoyed part
three together apart threes are good
I feel like we could probably enjoy the
other ones together now guys I'm just
gonna see me like 20 seconds I'm just
gonna fix this thing so I can get us
back on track here another good one for
me was Sin City
I watched Sin City with my whole family
watch that with me
no no nothing that none of the theaters
though like I not do it we bought Miss
Congeniality too so we picked that away
from each other yeah Miss Congeniality 2
tickets the theater was away over sold
of the usher guy came in with a
flashlight looking around we were in the
front row so we were like no I'll never
forget seeing in theaters but uh you
know later on a bit in life I was like
that that was one of those gamble movies
for me where I was like I could see this
working out cuz you know I grew up with
film noir I know my family loves the
film noir my sister just straight-up
didn't like that movie and I think I
think my mom and dad maybe got something
out of it I just still would feel
awkward cuz there's so much like you
know old town is all nudity you know
feel like John's got you know chunky
salsa I'm gonna ask you to stop putting
down milk and it's in the live stream or
I will have to block you mhm and I'm
gonna learn how to block people it's
easy you'll see I'll show you oh we got
a lot of people saying hereditary
American Pie in super bet yeah it's
weird how like these movies that
represent teenagers are like I'm not
that must be the most uncomfortable
experience or it seems like who the
actual representation of life you know
what happened I in I can't remember how
long ago this was this is like early
college I was with my first girlfriend
or yeah was my first girlfriend and her
family and mine became family friends
and they lent they were in they were the
family who would like to watch National
Lampoon like like Van Wilder together ha
and so they lent my my folks a bag of
DVDs and they were like oh watch these
comedies you're gonna love them and
they're literally all Van Wilder type
movies and I stared into this bag and I
was just like no none of this like even
if you guys
I had to watch it which I don't think
they ever did I was like I know that
this is not the bag for this family and
I'm not gonna try and be around when it
goes into the DVD player one time and
then we're gonna move on it was like
American Pie also and this is not
exactly the same thing I didn't watch to
my family but when I was really really
young there's a movie called Jerry
Maguire and then on the DVD players
maybe blu-ray I first saw this I never
had to use the option on a blu-ray but
on a DVD player you can have a like a
repeat moment you can time it or if you
like one like ten seconds yeah this is
before you get instant easy access to
pornography back then and there's his
mom where Tom Cruise is doing it with
this redhead chick it's [ __ ] Tom
Cruise right it's like it's like 10
seconds in the movie and I had it on
skip and we only have one DVD player and
that was in the living room and my
brother walked in on me with my pants
now so in some way I did watch Jerry
Maguire with my brother stood in the
doorway for a while before letting me
know he was why would three Cedric is
saying 300 be uncomfortable 100 the
sixth sense weird big sky I will throw
down for Game of Thrones though and I've
never watched a full episode with my
family and I've again had friends and
people be like you guys gotta watch this
and at least like but I think my dad
might be able to get into it maybe but
that was one where I was like especially
whenever a promo would come on TV I'd be
like mom I think you're gonna want to
switch this cuz yeah I know you're not
gonna like this oh and every time a
promo plays is pretty awkward all right
is that it that do it I think we have
hidden a user I think we have hidden
chunky salsa goodbye also hey it's like
the second time we've ever hidden
anybody Anisa
a liver thank you for your contribution
here again a John say it say hi to your
mother for me
I watched the real thank you for your
super chat I watched the real rejects in
my family and it was super uncomfortable
when it got to the gas jokes well yeah
why not on yourself
you're the one who encouraged the sex
jokes okay with your family this is
exactly what I was worried about said
you were gonna encourage you and then
somehow the footage is gonna be
manipulated and I'm gonna get in trouble
please and here it is now your mom's
gonna come breathing down the back of my
neck I just know it I'm just gonna send
you a shell gift card and pretend that's
what we met tell your mom I'm sorry and
happy Mother's Day to your mom and tell
her I'm switching to an electric vehicle
so I'm just plugging in at home from now
Mimi M thank you so much for your super
chat my dear hateful eight with the
whole family the worst I could see that
being a bit like just with ruthless
nasty some racist words in there getting
shot in the dick oh that could be a very
odd and the whole that's the movie if I
saw my mom today it would be very
uncomfortable undoubtedly
I wouldn't want to watch it with my mom
or sister I don't think I have but I saw
my dad we had a good time Mimi am so how
do your mother for me hey I heard Mark
Wahlberg doesn't appreciate that I could
see that so it's a good call me Mia yeah
all body heat that's a beauty dad worked
on body heat I think so no God sorry
Allah Oh old boy no Ronnie M in the chat
is saying old boy I'll watch it needs
akash a media with your hand so maybe
i'll give my girlfriend a clue if you
guys haven't seen oh boy I'm not gonna
ruin it for you there but there was
there's a big reveal twist in the movie
I went up to Olivia milady and I I just
got on my knees and I said I didn't know
she was my daughter and she's like what
[ __ ] movie are you I was like I'm not
gonna tell you what movie I'm doing but
one day we're gonna watch that movie and
I'm gonna look at you and go that's the
movie I was doing a year from now
years I saw old boy by myself and it was
still a wildly uncomfortable Oh brain in
your brain man yes movie 43 is just a
regrettable watching experience overall
Ryan Delahunt thank you for your super
chat my friend that's very much
appreciated he says I saw wolf of
wallstreet in the theatres of my parents
I was 15 we didn't talk the whole way
home oh I almost saw that with my
parents because they love martin
scorsese i saw my dad you saw that with
your dad our mother
i would hate to see that with your dad
oh yeah during the maserati she did a
different side come out of your daddy
started coke while watching the film
Jesus Christ that's uncomfortable you
saw your dad quaaludes seems like that's
how I met your mom no punches Mario
Robbie is like what the [ __ ] they watch
them watching our family lifestyle
before you were born your sisters wanna
lock you in the room yeah no you know
it's another one of those were yes that
was a 50/50 experience for me where I I
certainly appreciated that movie more
than my dad did I think we both got
something out of the experience however
I will say that a good percentage of
that movie was uncomfortable
basically all the sex parts especially
the full nude Margot Robbie we're a
little bit like I'm gonna pretend we're
not here oh god I cannot do man I'd be
more comfortable watch something with
your dad than your mom so [ __ ]
bizarre
I guess she would be quicker to make a
joke or something about it yeah or or
acknowledge the situation and something
it's like weird thing with your with
your family you know not your family
that's why you don't watch movies I've
like picked up rent was my mom reads
like a book a week and I picked up
random novels she's read that like like
The Godfather has like some real
descriptive sex scenes in there
and it's it's art when it's a book when
it's a book on literature there aren't
any actresses degrading themselves by
getting naked on big screen oh yeah me
me em who contributed the super Chad
she's bringing up the [ __ ] scene yeah
that was a Sina I wasn't thrilled to see
and I think the only reason it didn't
taint the overall viewing experience
with my dad was because the absurdity
hmm I think kind of edged yeah we were
both like oh but yeah there have been
more awkward moments for us personally
let's see here okay Josh Thank You Ryan
de Haan for that Joshua Rodriguez thanks
for your super chat buddy watch the John
Cena movie blockers of my mom and
girlfriend so many times my girlfriend
looked at me like oh my god we did that
why are we watching I gotta catch up
with blockers you be reminded of your
whimsical sexual encounters with your
girlfriend's mom right there that's feel
like my girlfriend zombie okay with that
what's up Theresa verify that if you're
watching like your daughter and I did I
would know my gosh she wouldn't I hope
she doesn't watch this then she'll some
Olivia text that'll be awkward
I hope Olivia's not was that's more like
knowing my luck Olivia will be like I'll
just watch it later yeah
Thank You Joshua what's right here more
milk
now other people are taking over the
milk thing Maria Hammond hey you're in
our chat thanks for being here my dear
mr. Magorium's wonder Emporium yeah use
regret spending the time uh-huh Dustin
Hoffman when's part 2 coming Magorium's
even more wonder importantly know is
saying Justice League nito red blue
velvet Oh agreed I'm sorry you had to go
through that don't sorry had to go
through that
yeah don't watch any of the heavier
David Lynch narrator [ __ ]
you [ __ ] but that's a good Mother's
Day reference mommy look at that it's on
topic random Andy's channel back in the
superjet game thank you my friend
a weird thing my parents did when I was
younger when two characters simply
kissed they told us to look away and
would quickly fast-forward like what all
it was was just simply kissing that's so
bizarre you've got a really bizarre
family we drug it's just kids
prostitution a gateway drug to anal
don't do it you know start kissing you
never know what's that Aaron's kissing
then next thing you know you got a wild
orgy going on you know you're women
dude I'm sorry you went through that
random Andy's Channel I mean what did
that do to your like with your sexual
nature I can imagine if I could not my
mind when I hear a comment like that
random a channel starts making me wonder
what extra repression lifestyle that
you've lead with that are you even
comfortable to look at yourself in the
shower
hmmm I mean I hope you super shower your
cellophane oh man yeah cuz that's the
thing too is is that does have an effect
on you and you don't I I didn't realize
it not to say that it's like the worst
in the world but it does affect the way
you develop I think you're those kinds
of feelings if like you know sex scenes
of any kind or just like you know so
yeah to have that with kissing is even
more yeah I'd be curious to hear more
about your here development
you got Zeke in the chat saying I agree
with Phantom Menace my dad fell asleep
oh that's just a bummer of a situation
right there he got some Rhett I feel
like it would be better almost watching
an awkward movie with a parent who falls
asleep but my dad would be okay if it
was like a movie he really loved like
The Shining he didn't try censor me at
all with the shining well cuz that's
freaky
was he like hey you want to watch this
together he would just put it off oh
just a lot or he wants the shining oh
well I watched a lot of The Shining
because those over my dad shoulder and
what naked old lady but I feel which is
a very conflicting scene by the way
because like the young woman's hottest
[ __ ] and then the old lady is like
that's why he didn't said to be those
because like it teaches you the lesson
especially when you're a kid who's prone
to being like guilt-ridden
you know cuz that boater down a bit yeah
cuz that seemed you know it's not sexy
by the end of it so that's very much
true John depending on your taste of
course okay so what do we got Silent
Hill I could see that there's some
pretty icky stuff in Silent Hill how did
you watch Sonic the Hedgehog before the
redesign with your family I want that
copy released this released the read the
pre-designed cut I thought people hey
Xander woman's last reaction video did
we did two yesterday buddy
yep just she hit the notification bell
the notebook that's uncomfortable
actually I could see that all those
emotions experience my family is a very
uncomfortable experience I don't like
crying these people well actually you
know I I'm very uncomfortable to cry at
a movie with my family because I'm
usually [ __ ] one crying look my mom's
crying then I'm okay my sister's crying
I'm okay if we're all crying if my
marching I don't know if my brother
would be cool like maybe nowadays my
brother would be cool but for some
reason my brain is telling me if I'm
crying at a movie and he's not crying
he's gonna make fun of me well watch the
movie yeah are you a [ __ ] the whole
time I really think that well we gotta
put it to the test now I want to see you
guys watch an impactful drama anew so
liver still doing the super chest on
your mom
I also watched blue is the warmest color
with my mom and brother recently yeah
the worst moment in my life what's blue
is the warmest color that is the lesbian
romance movie it's a foreign film it
came out a couple of years ago and I
have heard since that it was kind of
made a bit dubiously but yes it's a very
sexual thing you know this this topic
just became a lot more fascinating
because you're super chat Aneesa thank
you
because now I'm thinking with the fact
that there is more people quarantine
with their families they've probably
stumbled across a few movies together or
shows that they're probably
uncomfortable to watch with their family
because this is a recent experience for
you and you're unfortunately quarantine
with your family right now so I can
imagine how many more people have
stumbled upon some very unsettling
r-rated films since then yeah especially
now yeah you're more prone now to just
putting something on and checking it yes
rolling the dice maybe this will bring
families closer together though maybe
this will ice break some uncomfortable
conversations we got Jesslyn and the
chat same biggest regret watching shape
of water with dad and stepmom but that
was beautiful
when they started doing in the movement
the fit honestly it's funny my IRA
talked so much about family when my
brother hated that moment he hates that
when when the fit went and when she
agrees to have sex with fish boy right
when they did it in this movie I was
like [ __ ] yeah thanks for going there
because you wouldn't hold that punch and
I'm glad you guys did it this is gonna
be really upsetting for a lot of people
and they addressed the anatomy of how it
would work yeah yeah I agree
I can I feel like I saw that with my
family and I feel like I was feeling a
bit awkward but yeah I think the beauty
out waited we got a movie man mark great
youtuber Triple M say try watching Don
John with the fam oh no I would never
watch Oh God my food skirt
don't watch any movies about sex addicts
don't watch shame or anything like that
I know there's a bunch that I've seen in
my family that are very uncomfortable I
love the pics you guys are all putting
in this chat I love the ones that people
say in the chat that that that puzzle me
is on how that's uncomfortable like like
we got Robert here saying Independence
Day - when resurgent resurgence and
Suicide Squad why is that uncomfortable
because we all thought they were do they
beat you because you watched it with
taste
why would you suggest you watch this
crap amber Jones saying Watchmen watch
with her dad as a kid yeah I could see
that being a very especially during the
Silk Spectre at night al scene yeah yeah
gosh and the big blue dick yeah saw
devils reaiiy brought this up in the
last livestream I saw Devil's Rejects on
my mom and the feeders that was a very
unsettling especially in the shower when
they're in the hotel and then and then
he puts the hand gun down the woman's
crotch like oh my god yeah that's a
hardcore film you know what like those
are some uncomfortable moments to is
like I'll come in those are a special
kind because I'll come in sometimes just
channel surfing and like I remember once
my mom was flipping channels and she was
like oh how some of those and corpses
and she knows I like that movie and it
was one of those rows like okay it's on
during a scene that's fine
but I also don't want you to watch too
much to this cuz it's weird like I can
tell you it's not for you but somehow
you watching more of it and then like
knowing what it is that I like you know
it's gonna feel weird or something like
that oh someone in the chat said splice
I never saw I never saw splice but I
watched the scenes cuz they sounded they
sounded so ridiculous I'm like like
there's no way the movie would go that
far what they and then I I came across
the if you don't want to get splice room
for you I won't do it but there watch it
there's some some very strange
uncomfortable weird sci-fi sex up that
wasn't it that I was reading the text I
was like there's no way this movie would
do it yeah and and I watched a YouTube
video reaction of a people in the
theater who were watching it for the
first time that they just had to start
recording screaming oh my god no I can't
debate I'm doing a great promo to go
watch shocking even for me I was shocked
by what was going on yeah good good call
splice there sorry I missed your name in
here I'm trying to keep it with as many
comments as possible appreciate everyone
for being here by the way thank you okay
Erica Tuesday thanks for the super Chad
uh say hi to your mother for me one day
we will Jacuzzi it up again yes no weird
shout out coming your way by the way a
YouTube video she's she's super chatted
six dollars sixty six cents you devil
you
not today Satan at 30 I saw this movie
with my folks very uncomfortable [ __ ] at
13 I saw the devil's advocate with my
parents aunt and Grandma no the incest
and orgy sculptures scarred me and maybe
want to disappear out out of the theater
of course I saw that at home I could
have left the room and because they
didn't make me leave the room and it was
[ __ ] awkward yeah devil's advocate
great call bring him back some childhood
experiences right there that's for sure
literally all of this is making me just
so so so glad that I never watched under
the skin with my family I don't know why
I popped into my mind but yeah devil's
advocate oh that's tough II aliens also
got some messed up like religious
subtext room yeah alien versus Predator
I'm seeing a lot of the chat we're
trying to also keep up with some of the
super Chester you can get back to being
able to flash them on screen we're gonna
figure out OBS this coming week so that
way we can properly whoever cuz you know
don't super to be flashabou straight so
we're trying to catch up here you get
your flowers zombie strippers Zander
says you you get what you pay for
[Music]
let's see here let's see here
ed would Anissa was that awkward to
watch with your family who Robert is a
Lincoln I was like gotta get out of here
it's gonna be an awkward situation my
parents thought this was they were gonna
rewrite history
we projected it on our Union Jack flag
some people a lot of people in the chat
have been saying Game of Thrones I can
imagine that you know it area more
uncomfortable than yeah that a leg again
that move that show has been recommended
multiple times to my family with me in
the room and every time it's the most I
can do not to interrupt the person
because I'm just like I know I know it
in my bones if I show my mom this show
she's got hate it honestly I can totally
get why sex is more uncomfortable than
violence for anyone around the world
because I've kind of chalked it up to
the MPAA in the way we are as a culture
in America of how we're way more
uncomfortable with sex out here than we
are with violence yet movies and stuff
in the other parts of the world are way
more comfortable with sexuality but not
so comfortable with violence but I think
it could be more Universal with sex
being uncomfortable the watching your
family because we all have sexual desire
and it's something that's innate within
us and we can get reactionary and
triggered by it and drawn to it too
especially if we're in private when it
takes so much less time yeah it is
something that also parents are
concerned with their kids growing up
often of it I think they're naturally it
can be more uncomfortable just what's
and this is the taboo think is something
most of us want experience don't want to
talk about with their parents unless
were Chris Evans well yeah and I think
sex is a bit more complicated than a lot
of violence is right right just in the
nuances in the context and and you know
those kinds of feelings even just in
regular life can be very conflicting
yeah so I also get that point of light
I might not know how to explain this to
you you know we got matrix someone chess
a matrix to the sex scene yes
that could be very awkward I saw that
with my family too and it was
uncomfortable yes you know the most
uncomfortable and it came up again when
we were watching The Matrix - on TV for
a minute and it was the reason the
channel got changed was because it was
during the Merovingian scene were you -
what a moment
tune in for yeah I mean Ethan Holgate in
the chat saying something really really
true sex is aqua for some people to
watch violence is fun to watch with
meaning yeah bonds can be fun [ __ ] sex
I don't know
you know what joy it joyous sexy and fun
sexy is an underserved sexy all right we
are here Maria here random Andy random
Andy's channel back in the super chat
Howley doodlee he's saying you could say
hi to mother my mother yourself she's
been looking down from heaven for the oh
my god it's okay uh-huh
it's okay we didn't know we didn't know
you could say how do I bother yourself
she's looking up from her for the past
two years love your mom's and cherish
every moment you can't ask for a better
friend than a mother well yes but by us
saying say hi to your mother for me we
are saying hi to her right now
may she rest in peace I know what it's
like to lose a parent it's only been a
couple years I know how rough that can
be but you seem like you turned out to
be a pretty good kid you seem like you
love the hell out of your mom dude so
I'm sure she's proud of you and I'm
happy to know you and thanks for the
contribution by the way Heidi
hi to random Andy's channel mother hi to
random and what would you call her mrs.
room miss random Andy's Channel Madame
random and mater and Amanda Thank You
random and and this aback in here
thanks for the super chat Anissa Anissa
a nice nice of that awkward moment in
high school we were in the car with a
guy you friends out and he puts on puts
on grind on me by Pretty Ricky
yeah we're not friends
what who did that to you you should not
be friends with that guy yeah especially
if you already clearly friendzone him
cut it out Aneesa that's so weird I'm
sorry for doing that a nice I'm sorry
I really would love to have been a fly
on the wall for that what did he like
cueing up a song like that and expect
that they have some kind of profound
effect is fascinating to me before we
out here humans are gone girl gone girl
yeah over you I'll come oh man there's a
rat
no and in fact you know what he's is
John and I have it and the funny thing
is I'm glad I didn't watch it with my
family because they watched it together
and they were they hated that movie they
hated it they really don't like that
movie like I loved it but there is a
very uncomfortable sexy in that movie
that leads to something violent yeah
that you I would love to be in the room
with your family when they watch that
see you're welcome to try
I know I I don't fully regret it but I
felt pretty awkward watching the master
in theaters my dad I haven't seen that
yet I almost put it on the other day oh
you got some comfortable things to look
forward
Archer PA thank you for your super chat
dude he says mother hey Greg and John I
watched the movie her and my parents
were in the other room early on during a
specific scene my dad asked me if I was
watching porn in the living room and I
said kind of watching very thoughtful
melancholy porn oh yeah when he's like
doing the surrogate bit oh yeah when
he's first starts having sexual romance
with Samantha yeah he's like touching
himself ooh you know a masturbation
scene would be more uncomfortable for me
to watch in my family than with uh
that's a good call Archer PA kick-ass
that was one I thought I thought
kick-ass could maybe fly yeah at home
but I don't think it went over what like
the tone wasn't right and there's a
masturbation scene in that movie I saw
some movie when I was younger and I
don't know what it was that I watched my
family
hey cuz it was one of those movies they
rented but I did I didn't know maybe you
guys in the chat might be able to
pinpoint what this movie is this would
be a fun game for you guys so there was
something about like it was a little bit
historical kind of like maybe a hundred
two hundred years ago it takes place and
it was like these these these lesbians
and then they want to kill the mom and
then by the close to the end of the
movie they start beating the [ __ ] out of
the mom with a rock like they're like
smashing it on her face there's blood
coming down her as it's real horrific
scene that's all I was like I'm wasn't
even like ten years old my god I can't
place no idea what this movie is all I
have are like fragmented images a bit of
like these lesbians who plot to kill one
of the lesbians mom and then they beat
the [ __ ] out of her with a rock it's
very brutal stuff I don't even have a
guess all I can think of his lucky
Maki's the woman which I'm really happy
I didn't watch with my family Oh someone
in the chat saying watch with her mom
Magic Mike I watch it with my mom cuz
I'd be worried she's into it I'd be more
uncomfortable my mom being into like
sexually aroused by something you know
beautiful creature heavenly creatures
wait are beautiful creatures and
heavenly creatures different why would
that be awkward that's like a teen
romance right oh okay so we got archer
PA here we thank you Archer PA and nice
l liver back at it again
Thank You Anissa also action industries
is live at the same time y'all are now I
have to choose Oh what Ben LOL jk it's a
no brainer besides I watched them
earlier don't you dare leave our live
stream for theirs
don't you dare when we were on their
live stream just this past week you
already contributed to the super chat I
don't need to be there anymore you can
unsubscribe as soon as you can I don't
want to see you in there Jeff I'm just
kid
if you want to go to action mysteries
they are great gentlemen and they
deserve more support so yeah but I
really hope you don't [ __ ] leave and
go over to there but thank you for
letting me know and Issa you could
always watch it after you're finished
here I'm interested in this one right
here Thank You Aneesa thank you you're
so sweet and needs to send me this video
on Instagram that was a Chloe grace
Moretz interview about you know the lack
of inequality in the industry and when
she realizes sixteen years old how she
was being sexualized by producers who is
a very fascinating interview and I have
been Chloe grace Moretz like she has a
[ __ ] work ethic and she is a straw
like I found to be a very empowering
interview I'm not even like a woman but
I found it like to be a very empowering
insightful interview so thank you for
sharing that with me
let's Greg we're answering your
questions oh what heavenly creatures the
movies with movies heavenly creatures so
it's not beautiful creatures okay there
we go
heavenly Corrine heavenly creatures is
the movie by Peter Jackson damn damn
what genre I've never seen this movie oh
my goodness melanie lynskey and and Kate
Winslet oh my god I can finally overcome
my traumas like this oh yeah see 94 I
told you what I was like I know I'm not
a kid I know I wasn't even like 10 when
I saw this man Heavenly Creatures what
should i type in to make sure this oh
this is definitely the movie we should
react to the trailer silently thank you
guys for finding the movie thank you
guys
oh thank you I'm glad you know what just
for you know our people who tune in here
it makes me very happy that y'all were
able to pull together a deep cut like
that Michael Williams thank you so much
for your super
that's buddy Thank You Deadshot versus
bullseye Deadshot versus bullseye well
if we're talking Will Smith's if we're
an oversight tracking here but you know
you contribute the super chest we got it
uh uh first bullseye if we're talking
Will Smith's Deadshot versus Colin
Farrell's bull's eye I think by what's
displayed on screen it would be Will
Smith's Deadshot I think if it was Will
Smith's Deadshot versus that bullseye
from daredevil season three I would give
it up to that bullseye there's your
answer
fair enough what about you guys in the
livestream who do you think will win
Deadshot or bullseye I would say
bullseye uh yeah for some reason I feel
like it would be yeah I'm so I'm so
happy that you guys found that heavenly
creatures must have been really popular
because the fact that I was able to
remember to slight fragment cuz I
remember the like they're laying in a
bathtub at one point so I'm like oh they
must be gay and Stan's crazy but yeah so
fascinating all right all right Mimi I'm
back in the super chat Thank You Mimi M
watch knocked up with a group of about
ten family and friends about ten family
members and family friends at my
grandmother's house I was 11 complete
Hawk would silence her every moment
that's like you know a knocked-up would
have been a very uncomfortable movie for
me to watch my family to me me because
when you're especially what I want to
laugh at something cuz then I'd know I
know my family's gonna judge me for
finding it funny and they're gonna think
something negatively about me for
finding a sex comedy funny yeah
and they're gonna tell me that it's not
fun I'm like you can't change my mind on
what's funny yeah yeah you know unless
it's like I'm watching Saving Private
Ryan and I'm laughing hysterically
during the first opening battle arias
then there's then you could do question
what I find funny but if something is
intended for a comedic purposes and I'm
laughing you can't change that now I
just feel bad for finding it funny so
I'm sorry you went through that Mimi
I can imagine that being a very
uncomfortable experience oh goodness
yeah especially your grandma's house
Giselle's saying they watched donkey
punch with the family she's correct how
your family has to be into likes
esoteric films if you watch donkey punch
together
did you just randomly find it was this
oh Amber's clarifying in the livestream
that Magic Mike was uncomfortable oh
whoa she's saying it was uncomfortable
watching Magic Mike because they were
both attracts the men during the movie
oh what a weird shared experience I see
it yeah it's like on the in the general
I think that's endearing and I wish that
could be league that's endearing if you
like you're watching a movie Magic Mike
with your mom and you and your mom both
find the magic Mike's hot all right John
let's play the scenario okay let's say
you're watching showgirls with your dad
you and your dad watching show I'm not
saying I wouldn't be uncomfortable
your dad's attracted your dad's clearly
turned on by what's on screen and you're
turned on and let's say your dad does a
little bit of a would that be [ __ ]
weird I guess so I
yeah I guess the okay if you're both
sitting there going these people are
attractive and we can both appreciate
that in the mood is light that's one
thing if you're if you're both going I'm
getting worked up right then yeah I
don't want to be a part of that but if
you have an open enough you know family
communication comfortability to the
point where you're like I think they're
attractive too that's that's fine with
me
if you're both like I need to find a
closet or something real quick like then
no thank you
you and your dad fight for the closet
after showgirls I can see it happening
with your dad
it's up Bruce Hey Bruce Hey
a lot of people throughout this whole
livestream that we've been live a lot of
people have been mentioning a sausage
party I feel like people were very
misled they thought it would just be
like an like a raunchy dialogue driven
comedy
yes that's the problem with the fact
that we in the West at least kind of
assume animations for kids only because
I have a feeling there were a lot of
uncomfortable family viewings of that
movie hey amber if you were comfortable
with your mom doing it then okay I don't
judge I'm saying if I was in your
position I'd be uncomfortable but if
you're not you're a little uncomfortable
though different men
I regret watching Chucky with Nica sorry
all right here we go hey and there are
people who are thinking that we might
have missed your super chats don't worry
we haven't we're just hopping around
between like the regular livestream
chats and we and we're we're trying to
make sure we're reading everyone's
spread the love but ya know where if you
did commit if you didn't contribute a
super chat we will be reading yours out
loud trust me with a proper thank you
this is back in the soup and maybe the
game hell yeah what's up Aneesa sad your
mother for me again I'm kidding I love
the gas jokes lol she doesn't even know
we were talking about ha well in case
your mom doesn't know we were talking
about with the gas joke's on you endo
basically that I we have an ongoing joke
aneesa's mom I hope you're watching we
have an ongoing joke that John will bang
you at the gas station one day and this
was aneesa's idea so don't blame me
aneesa's mom or me just saying this was
a nice idea we were just honoring her or
commentary wishes no your wish is our
command Nancy hey Nancy Oh you need to
change your username I recognize your
profile is she chant you changed your
username in the middle of this live
Street and thank you for your super chat
Nancy not awkward but when I rented
Napoleon Dynamite I remember Napoleon
Dynamite I walked out of that movie
thought it was ridiculous and then I was
laughing about it with some the same
friends I walked out of that movie with
and were like it was actually got a
funny let's go back and watch it went
back a week later thought it was funny
enough it was just on the other night so
I saw a good half of it for the first
time in years with Jon Heder Jon Heder
yeah
poor guy and oh damn who played Pedro
because he went on to do some stuff -
the thing with John here in Napoleon -
I'm gonna properly read your super
China's second Nancy but yeah the thing
with Jon Heder I remember what happened
was we were like he was a character so
well Napoleon Dynamite and then they saw
him in like interviews and other movies
and they realized he kind of just comes
across a little bit like Napoleon so if
it was something where he came across
totally different he might have had a
longer career scene I think he couldn't
break out of the Napoleon Dynamite image
I can see that I've be curious to hear
what he sounds like now but I like to
know is he was fighting blades of glory
he's won more like I've seen him in a
few other things no I like you I wish
you yeah head stuck a little more anyway
Nancy bacheior super chat not awkward
but when I rented Napoleon Dynamite my
mom baffled asked if that was what
passed for humor with my generation I
could understand
I can get that I feel like that was
another one where you know what those
were two movies and hot rod was a more
intense version of this because I think
I saw a Napoleon Dynamite first with my
dad in the theaters so I had a little
backup but but yeah I feel like bringing
it home especially hot rod that first
viewing was so flat and so awkward and
so quiet and I couldn't even laugh
because it is that thing you're talking
about where I like I don't laugh when no
one's enjoying this yeah but then all of
a sudden like it had that same effect
we're kind of stuck in everyone's brain
and now like whenever it's on we
watching so it was almost this but not
Quinton Logan in our live stream nice to
see you here buddy
okay kind of fine what's a movie we
haven't mentioned yet because you got
understand people come in and out of the
livestream lover so I want to be naming
movies that people have a name D yet or
we have them called out yet Love
Actually
III saw Love Actually in the theaters
with us there
oh yes with family friend and it was
David Henry his mom was in the theater
with us and David's younger brother
Lorenza was in there too and ran in
there
I don't know but that brands irrelevant
to the story and then there was so much
sex happening in that movie with the
porn stuff one couple and that that
David's mom and David and David's
younger brother out of the theater and
then went to go watch something else
watch the rest of the movie yes I
remember feeling really awkward telling
my like when it was first revealed that
I had seen it but I feel like we've
watched it since then and the the the
like sweetness of of the couple like
transcends that so we can watch Levesque
it's true okay so that's a rare example
actually of like a movie with a lot of
nudity that we can usually make it
through without much issue Michael
Williams hey thanks for your super chat
dude back at him
I regret watching monsters ball that
monster's ball was one of the first
movies I brought up and during this live
stream I watched that with my brother
who dad it was very awkward because of
that one sex scene and she ran in my
room and thought I was watching porn say
I haven't had that I mean I shared that
experience with you on monsters Bob how
so strongly of an uncomfortable
experience I was for me to watch my
family
have you seen monsters ball no watch
some movies John okay I know when you're
about to say no yeah I can tell there's
a hesitation when you have seen a movie
or go I've seen the sex scene from
monsters ball it was so many years ago
probably I don't know he was probably on
TV or something or maybe somebody rented
it um yeah not yet did they do it in
real life in in that scene or just
seeing it realize I've heard they did it
for real in the scene but I would
believe they did
I feel like Billy Bob and and and Halle
Berry would get down I've never had a
moment in my life where I'm watching
something that has sex in them my
parents come in and they think that I'm
watching a porn you know well plenty of
people in this life never said that
they've had that happen to them like are
you watching porn I've never had that
happen to me has anybody ever had it
happened where you're watching like
because sometimes you know cries of
agony can mirror
cries of ecstasy so has anybody ever
been like watching a horror movie where
like some girls like you know screaming
and moaning in pain and somebody from
the other room is like are you watching
a porno I feel like that has to happen
at some point because you know I feel
like you could also use that as an
excuse people are talking in the live
Stern about the movie revenge yeah that
would be a very uncomfortable movie to
watch your family members so watch
revenge with your family I don't want
irreversible with your family I want I
Spit on Your Grave with your friend yeah
you know those are people in this live
stream who have been saying they watch
like irreversible with their family now
I can believe that someone might have
accidentally stumble on that there's
people were saying they watch Serbian
film with their family
I don't believe you did there's no way
now you know wedding here sir sir again
ex thanks for your super chat dude watch
swordfish with my parents at the
drive-in theater another Halle Berry
movie who got to Halle Berry super chat
mentions in the rough got awkward when
that scene where Hugh Jackman was
getting head in the movie when I sat
between my parents oh yeah yeah where he
has to do the hack what a weird scene I
forgot about that a weird tooth that was
like the early 2000s right that's that's
a very it seems like that kind of era
scene I was so stupid yeah a John
Travolta with that like quintessential
early 2000s cool guy hair and goatee
combination I could see the if you guys
haven't seen swordfish basically John
Travolta is looking to recruit a hacker
play by Hugh Jackman and in order for
him to determine if he can work under
pressure he assigns some girl to like in
random it just happens suddenly against
Hugh Jackman's wish ins to start
performing oral sex on him while he's on
a lap while he's like trying to hack
into something and I could see the
writer of that being like oh this would
be so sexy and cool that's probably just
his roleplay
keep it for your intimate desire why
would the nice guys be an uncomfortable
movie to watch with your family really a
great movie
The Wrestler yeah yeah I mean depending
on the age you're at I could see how
that could be in a way no there's some
like pretty nice having sex with chicks
I saw my dad in the theaters it wasn't a
regrettable experience but those moments
for a little bit awkward what we were
just talking about right before that
fish if it comes back to me it comes
back to me what's the inbetweeners I
know is that uh there's people in the
chat saying we got to start watching it
I don't know I don't know we got hired
but then I feel like I lose the person
ability when we're not well this is the
charm is the sort of you know plucky
were DJing we're looking around I think
we're almost catching up on the super
Chester we start flashing them on the
screen air we're so almost there
Britney laying Britney Lang's back here
Thank You Britney laying wait a minute
I'll go back to Sarah gain access super
checks out of a drive-in theater I want
to go to one experience there are some
that still run their planes swordfish I
guess I guess they've been around for a
while and that must have been the big
movie
Britney laying can't think of any movie
thank you for your super chat keep
changing that profile pic every week I
wish we were caught up to the point
where we can flash it on screen we will
get proper OBS hold on a second we could
try not to make sure okay Britney Lange
thank you thank you my dear can't think
of any movie with this question of the
week but just wanted to stop by and say
hi well thank you for saying hi in the
best possible way through Thank You
Britney very sweet of you I hope happy
Mother's Day to you you are a mother
Mother's a to you Britney now now watch
a serbian film with your daughter and
then okay I think we're here we are
we're
we're done said I got six one six what a
major contribution here maybe we caught
goodness gracious I thank you so much
that a big contribution do you thank you
I asked my aunt to take me to go see J
oh I saw that with my family that was
Jay and Silent Bob strike back when they
came out of theaters I was 13 need i say
more
whoa are we the same age when did Jay
and Silent Bob come out because yeah a
2001 I guess you're probably a couple
years older than us yeah I don't blame
you I saw that with my family too and I
and if I don't know what point in this
live stream you came in on the on the
chat but my family not a fan of crude or
vulgar humor at all they were kept there
Catholics so it was watching them just
like 10 shoulders the whole time
you know it's funny and I real quick I
did get it based off the Jay and Silent
Bob I did get a crush on Eliza Dushku
after that oh yes yes I remember when
she hit the scene yeah it's funny cuz I
feel like I dodged an awkward family
viewing bullet because there was a
moment in time where like I remember my
family was really into Dogma but I
wasn't allowed to watch it was except
for the [ __ ] monster scene so I feel
like that would have been and also the
nice guys that's what it was I get it
because of the porn stuff and because
like there is some like but it's not
like there's that like the chick is like
idyllic and dead and naked at the
beginning but yeah that's a movie that
like another one more when it's on we
just watch it was like I yes that was
one I took my family to I'm rarely
confident enough and in like my taste
appealing to other people to be like we
got to go watch this that was a movie I
saw I was like you know what guys we all
got to go watch this because I think
we're good time and we saw that hey
Deadeye six one six thank you again for
such a big-ass super chat thank you
that's really kind of you oh my goodness
yeah Verdugo's and I am i refresh the
chat to make sure we're caught up and
somehow
I messed up on here I am good we need
more we need a different we're gonna get
a different live stream service I
promise or we're gonna figure out OBS or
to properly showcase everyone
contributed is super chat but what are
people talking about in the just a
normal chat what are they I love reading
your guy it's fun looking in the live
stream because you guys are go back and
forth so it's always fun seeing the
subscribers interact with each other the
Wolfman 2010 my mom and I went to see
together in the theaters and we actually
enjoyed it so I don't share that with
you piranha 3d would definitely tho be
awkward to watch with her family Giselle
saying King ping with my uncle you know
what was really uncomfortable I saw I
saw King pin the the miniseries on NBC
and sometimes it surprises the hell out
of me what NBC can get away and yeah
there was there's some crazy-ass that
was very uncomfortable watch out my mom
I regret seeing part of kingpin on TV
with my family and those Farrelly
Brothers man when they're not curing
racism they like to be raunchy alright
Anthony Paul goodbye not yes we if you
start spamming gone I like Brian the
tools Leon don't worry guys like
Valentine's Day why would that be an
uncomfortable movie to watch with your
family cuz you know everybody just
starts getting hot over Taylor Lautner
Bernie alvarado back image on the live
stream he is saying Evil Dead the
tracing the remake one is worse yeah it
is the originals kind of ambiguous but
the remake one is like very direct the
original has at least one or two very
non ambiguous shots to that sequence
because there's like there's a crotch
shot that the remake doesn't have oh
really
remember there was a direct hit yeah in
fact I've heard it said I don't know the
trueness of this but I've heard it said
the Sam Raimi actually kind of regrets
putting that in for the kind of meme
it's become mmm because that wasn't the
intent obviously yeah but yeah is the
inbetweeners is that like a is that like
an Australian horror thriller or some
like that I feel like I've heard the
title but yes man the [ __ ] Sam seemed
Frasier talking about in the livestream
that's true it's a [ __ ] scene yes
ma'am it's implied she takes offered her
to eat her teeth the old woman all right
Verdugo silver thanks for your super
chat my dude do go
butter do go silver say hi to your
mother for me watch John wick 3 with my
uncle not realizing my 9 year old cousin
would be joining oh no at what point in
the watching experience wait a minute
your uncle shoulda thought that's John
wick 3 it's not John wick 1 your uncle
should have known better
yeah I watched Shawn work through my
uncle not realize my 9 year old cousin
joining she had to leave when the guy
got slowly stabbed in the eye I mean
[ __ ] that's art yeah I when I read your
super chat hear that that sounds like
you feel responsible but you have no
reason to be at fault it's John wick 3
it's John look leg did was there
literally nothing else to watch and you
had to watch something if he saw half of
John wick 1 he would know what he's
walking into with John wick and unless
he's like you don't never seen gentle
because you're watching and you're like
yeah [ __ ] come I'm cool I mean wig
was your cousin there from the start or
was it like over 5 minutes and by the
way come into your bud we're watching
yeah sorry sorry you went through that
dude sorry about your cousin hopefully
your cousin's not traumatized hopefully
your cousin your 9 year old cousin
doesn't grow up and become some type of
serial killer because they accidentally
watched John whiff 3 with you for Hugo
that's what I'm really worried about for
you maybe they'll just become overly
protective pets let's see here yeah
Inbetweeners is a UK raunchy comedy I
feel like I've heard of The Inbetweeners
yeah I've heard the name definitely but
is that the what was the show that James
Corden did I know it's not being between
her so is the show James quarter worry
before he got the the James Corden show
oh I'm not sure I know is like earlier
movie work and stuff like that I
remember
American Pie have seen a few people on
the livestream mention American Pie I
saw that with my own my family - that's
a classic I don't want to watch this is
my family movie you guys gotta
understand there was a time way before
and so happens it's easier to avoid this
[ __ ] now because you can you got there's
a there's a website like my girlfriend
she cannot stand animal deaths and
movies so there's a website called does
the dog die calm and this is good if
your parent out there I feel like
there's a good Mother's Day tip if you
happen to be here today by the way I
believe it was Miss movies happy
Mother's Day to you by the way I believe
it was her who told me about this
website first and does a dog calm will
basically tell you like this or alcohol
as her drugs is her violence is like
it's a animal deaths what kind of
animals they get very is a lot of
questions and it's very descriptive so a
lot of times of about to watch a movie
where I feel like there could be an
animal death I'll look it up on this
website to make sure if there's an
animal death or not and I forgot why I
brought up this website it was the point
that you were getting at the the idea
that nowadays is really easy
oh yeah what content you can prevent
because even on MPAA ratings i remember
they used to not say why something was
rated PG or pg-13 or R yeah you'd never
know there was pervasive language
automatic element if it was just cause
of strong language or some smoking and
more a scene of sex intense depictions
of weathers is a real one so now it's as
though it's just a giant gamble now back
then it was a gamble you didn't know
exactly what remember that like that's
yeah is like before you could rent a
pg-13 movie and still have a chance of
regretting that yeah now I don't feel
like it's as obvious hey Bernie Alvarado
and the super chess thank you Barney
Alvarado happy Mother's Day to your
mother Oh mother
deserve universal healthcare laid but
total leaf movie I regret watching my
parents Hot Tub Time Machine no way I
could not have known my folks
no no way in hell could I allow my folks
lots of there's some ranch in that movie
alaya wife from Mad Men in them my
brother is pretty my brother Jabba
Kuwait there's this really funny
Instagram account called Jabby Achara
memes that always does these names of
like how Jabby constantly talks about
his ex-girlfriend's so he's either
generally a lot more comfortable talking
about like relationship stuff sex stuff
than I am but I still feel this
childhood subconscious thing that if
even if it's a sex comedy like Hot Tub
Time Machine I would still be
uncomfortable to watch it with my
brother just go off in my brain like I
shouldn't be laughing at this yeah like
when I was going by the whole Ryan
Wright thing I would be uncomfortable to
be right I'm a brother if you don't yeah
if you don't connect on on that
wavelength then totally yeah because
yeah it's like I don't have I I didn't
have that thanks for your super chat
Bernie you don't mess with the Zohan
that's an uncomfortable one adds a
family favorite in my house but I can
see why Anissa I miss Blockbuster Video
- I loved paying like $18 for a five day
rental great well you know when when
Netflix was killing them they started to
get real for them in Hollywood video I
missed them - yeah I see one way
remember artisty video Odyssey video
they were dead the brink of going away
for like ten years
I know but once they were the last
videos door I thought it would work out
me me saying King's been the Golden
Circle really Ethan yeah I wouldn't like
half of my brain was like we could watch
the second Kingsman movie but like
there's some there's at least one
sequence in that scene that I just
wouldn't want to have to talk about
Gavin and Stacey is the James Corden
show Thank You Daniel John by the way
it's got me curious guys who and
whoever's in the live show right now
just a quickly maim what country you're
in right now what's our if you're in the
u.s. what state you're in
Oh fun - no zero true
octi analytics with the live stream here
I remember when Eurotrip was like such a
huge deal and yeah that's I feel for you
if you watched now if you're feeling
that or road trip see you America would
your dad and sister Jacob oh my god I
cannot handle that whatever when I read
the pics you guys put I just immediately
put myself in my situation with my
family and I'm just like no I I watch
team America with my Valen and it went
over okay alright so I just I just threw
out there in the livestream whoo-hoo
what country or state you're from God TM
in Texas Alejo Ricardo Rico Washington's
at Washington Arizona Texas desert
Ireland Giselle's from Ireland for
Ireland Amber Jones from England
I'm the gem we got we got we got
Philadelphia Pennsylvania Indiana
passage Massachusetts [ __ ]
[ __ ] Illinois we got a nice of
course Texas in the Netherlands as
Orleans so you don't feel awkward about
anything
soda Canadians are out this is fun a lot
of Ireland people from all different
places
Quebec holy [ __ ] I always want to say
Philadelphia way days Wales that's where
a Christian Bale's from when he switches
in and out of accidents now actually
that go Illinois we just watched a
doctor who ever saw that took place in
Wales Wow
thank you guys hey guys so cool I'm all
parts of the world
[ __ ] zoom meetings this is what it's all
about Oh Mimi is in California one day
we'll bump into each other
Arkansas from Jacob K Chris wham off
dude you got to respond to me on patreon
man Kalamazoo Kalamazoo Michigan that's
right thank you guys all right Jones boy
I'm Bajans are you doing let's see here
who we own and random a news channel
thanks again for another super chat dude
okay so if you guys are kind of tuning
in just now I was talking cuz random man
channel sounds like with his upbringing
when it came to sensory movies I was
curious as to know what it's like others
kinds of sexual repression issues that
might have potentially led to because I
want her to have a psychological
discussion needed to get there as a fan
he said as a family a man who believes
sex after marriage as a family who
believes in sex after marriage us kids
knew our parents would kill us and grass
for a long time from you and hanging out
with the opposite sex
Oh I made out once 10 years ago okay so
you yourself also oh he said Shh
I thought you were telling me
destruction oh [ __ ] that I do John no
just don't mention that make it are
these beliefs that that you hold there
carried for further or did they inspire
you to not live I am i I can identify
with that growing up Catholic
there was a point for like a week where
I contemplated going into priesthood so
I told
just [ __ ] were like you're not gonna
do that yeah because I was very adamant
to at one point in my life well wait
until sex waiting to have sex until
after marriage around the time of 17 I
changed my mind and then when I was 28 I
really changed but no respect if you're
gonna wait that long I mean I know
someone I know someone I won't say who
because it's very private but I know
someone who like was had a lot of sexual
encounters in his life and then he
became a born-again known I became like
a very devoted Catholic down the road
and he didn't even kiss kiss his now
wife who he has a child with until the
day of their wedding
that's how strict he was that's how
bigoted Catholic he was Kevin James I'm
good friends with Kevin
you can't get the j-man go I know some
people alright but thank you and at
Matty's Chow for being willing to be
open and share Zach Gallaudet dude oh
what an interesting one Zeke Zeke Gallo
sorry what an interesting one almost odd
in class a teacher try to put up a piece
of paper for the nude scenes hashtag
action nice burn i'ma start in class
well you went to film school yeah can
you relate with this one at all with
like what you see like why should be
reversible in film school that was
exactly the point the we didn't watch
the whole film but I sooo though we had
a project where we had to bring in clips
and break them down and you know know
what the cinematography was doing for
the various scenes or whatever and
somebody brought in the scene from
irreversible like not even just a snow
the worst scene you can in yeah we all
didn't want yeah I mean if you guys
haven't seen her irreversible it's a
it's like a 17-minute
a sexual assault scene yeah right yeah
yeah I don't know if we watched all 17
minutes but we watched oh yeah it was it
was it was very awkward when it was one
of those things where you could feel the
gears in in the teachers head turning of
do I stop this did you okay my question
now is were you friends with people in
that class did you guys like chat about
the awkward experience it was afterwards
or he's just like [ __ ] it we leave I
can't remember how quickly the ice broke
but we definitely talked about because
somebody had to somebody had to go after
that somebody else had to present clips
and so like there was like a Finding
Nemo or something like there was
something very friendly after that jeez
but yeah I mean we there may have been
an ice breaking joke and yet it was I
love this comment in the live stream
someone say for the topic movies you
were go watching your family
Blair Michael is saying this Blair Witch
Project because of the strong language
specific that it's you sound like an
MPAA rating and an intense scenes of
peril is Amistad like the the nudity and
Amistad isn't it's got to be like you
know not for sex titillating purposes
right yes bill Berg was a perv man
because like I feel like if you're
watching something like let's like oh do
you remember that nudity and I remember
being very violent yeah because I feel
like you know it's if you watch say
Schindler's List in school there are
some scenes in which there is mass
nudity and I feel like I'm kind of
surprised that you know the paper
treatment got put up for something
that's based in history basically I feel
like the history angle is always where
you can get by but Kate Kate is watching
this live stream right now from Houston
Texas what while watching Netflix with
her mom she's nuts thanks for being here
Kate thanks for doing the dual screen
life so many people here so many people
from all the different parts of the
worlds yes I mean West Covina California
guys haven't seen crazy ex-girlfriend
highly underage you jump on it jump on
it yes right what Dom Assad they weren't
naked for sexual purposes of slaves or
just naked okay I gotcha all right
that's kind of what I was thinking yeah
so at that point I feel like you know
for solidarity sake you show it but okay
random Annie's channel thanks for thanks
again for another super shot dude
thank you you guys made me happy cry
love you all oh dude I Love You Man
thank you random and thank you for being
here man and and thank you for like
hanging out with us like several
weekends just like being I know she's
you're here every week thank you for
being here you [ __ ] Rock if we could
make you happy cry even for a second
that's actually that's that means a lot
but do you know who's here for sure
every week and every minute of the live
streams are new Sony sir Eric but I know
that Eric I'm usually to forget Eric
goes in and out he's zigzags I'm sure I
think he's in here now but he said he
got here like
it's a nice yes Anisa thank you again
for your super check I agree with random
Andy my family is a sex after I love
this live stream has now slowly
converted but I agree with rendering
taste live stream my family is a sex
after marriage family and it's hard to
be honest them without being shunned
well maybe you should stop trying to
have sexual encounters with John and
they will stop shunning you and ISA
we'll meet at church alright do it in
the confessional booth cuz I mean I'm
sure is that while mass is going on at
church do it in a Pew in the back don't
even hi which I'm sure all these things
have happened so I'm sorry what movie
was it where they do it in the come in a
confessional was that you're a trip I'm
trying to think
ah Thank You Cedric for the comment on
the last rooms but I appreciate that
Emo's watch this rip Virginia what's up
more army of Darkness was an awkward
watch I still need to see dark man
though I want to see dark man am i
making I want to say something to you
said the venom 2 trailer sketch with
warm was bloody hilarious thank you oh
no what
as people don't realize there was a
sketch and we had people asking us when
was your last sketch and I'm like so it
was a sketch the idea was to there's one
of those like secret schedules we don't
realize that was punished am calles
pissed off for a comment someone in the
chat is saying I know a couple had sex
at church a few times Jesus Christ
people Jesus their ex out there man
there's a rush to be had all right
legendary Deadeye thanks for your super
chat legendary Deadeye Deadeye dick
happy mother's day to your mother
glad your mother pushed you out of her
vagina it's bringing hair day or a guy
you c-section
or if you don't know your mom and you
were like an orphan child I'm glad that
whoever took care of you as your mother
figure was able to say you know I'm
trying to get out here since the corona
virus outbreak is starting to calm down
and the cases are going down do you
think some movies and theaters will
reopen sooner than later
I certainly hope not they will but I
hope they will okay based off your
question legendary yet I think again for
the super chat there was there was a
there's this Park I go running at
because there's a lot of space it's
isolated it's easy to keep like like way
more than six feet distance from people
that I go running it and I wear a mask
still when I run I'm cautious like that
and I have hand sanitizer and baby wipes
in my car too so that way where I'm done
running before I even take my mask off I
can clean the [ __ ] out of my hands and
stuff so that way I just I wrote in my
face right but near there is a golf
course which has been shut down and and
then today because now as of yesterday
some retail some small businesses are
able to start reopening the parking lot
was just jam-packed and all these people
are going golfing right now and I'm just
imagining just how many people are in a
rush to want like I'm sorry I was
talking with Dan cyber from that cyber
channel just about this yesterday of I'm
not used to the regular lifestyle of a
lot of other people who because I'm used
to just being at home looking through a
YouTube channel so I can imagine there's
a sense of like need to want to get out
of the home but I want a movie theaters
I really don't think we should be
rushing to get movies out right like
especially I mean thinking from the
movie perspective from the studio
perspective if how much money you
actually gonna make you want to start
releasing your movies when literally
much show
if people feel comfortable to go out to
the theatres and it's gonna be a while
till most like we're it's like a pretty
or it's like you're kind of weird for
not be it's gotta get to the point where
you're a real isolated scenario if
you're someone who doesn't want to go to
a theater gets to the point where if you
get Cova then you can then we can deal
with it yeah when we can deal with it
then yeah and they're talking about yeah
reopening things pretty soon and putting
a plexiglass and stuff like that and on
the one hand I'm like okay beta-test
that sure but I I think some theaters
are probably already open know there are
some states that are just open I don't
think they should I don't think they
should be just reopening right now I
don't think it seems smart it doesn't
seem smart I know there's a big like
conspiracies going around debates
I know Elon Musk was a big part of that
because it's like this kept up with Elon
my stuff I know he named his baby
something interesting and I really think
he really thinks he's just reopened
completely in is very much against they
think there's a lot of like the numbers
are blown out of proportion the fact of
the matter is what I would say is we
don't know for sure there's no way any
of us we can agree or disagree with Elon
Musk or whatever or any of the people
who believed along the lines of him we
don't know for sure I'd rather be safe
than sorry
bottom line yeah I mean once that's just
that's just it I'd rather be safe than
sorry maybe you all musk is right but we
don't know for sure but I do know for
sure is the reports that are coming out
you know yeah and I mean from having
seen and heard reports from both people
I don't know people I do know who have
had it it it certainly seems like a
pretty awful experience and so even if
it wasn't you know potentially deadly
yeah I don't know what do you guys think
if they start reopening theaters next
month would you start going back in tell
us in the live stream yo thanks your
question alleged the superjet Nancy back
with another super chat thank you didn't
realize I had my old account old screen
screen name on this I thought she said
she said on her under a comic she said
didn't realize I had my old SN on this
account
she was met say SSN in reference to her
social security number and I was gonna
say put the new one in
can you super chat us your social
security number you super tell us your
identity well hey I'm happy to know your
actual name Nancy and yes we only
profile pic lovely profile pic lovely
anis ops is back back at it again Anissa
with the super chest and we're almost
come back up in stream queen of the
super chats are you also are y'all
trying to get in trouble I thought you
all are on my side you're all supposed
to back me out haha if I remember Greg
started at the gastro I start at the gas
station joke about John doing you at the
gas station but I was like it was an
ambiguous one it was like a subtle hint
and you were like no Greg can go all out
there no I go all out go extreme with
initiative alright no question no leave
it up to imagination and now now we're
in a position where I have really
uncomfortable moment with your mom and
if you need me to talk with your mom I
will but I'm warning you I won't I'll
charm the hell out of your mom she's
gonna come on meet her at the guests I
know I know her mother's day is gonna be
a wonderful present when she meets Greg
Alba I'm telling you and ISA so it's
president Mother's Day any time a mother
meets correct every day should be
Mother's day every month should be black
history she's got a couple more here
thank you for your multiple super chats
in a row Nisa so sweet to us you're so
sweet the grapefruit seen in girls trips
so awkward haven't seen girls trip is it
anything like the peep scene from call
me by your name Oh oh thank God I didn't
watch that with my family and another
off-topic question from Anissa another
off-topic question can you all read each
other's minds at moments the job and
friends for so long or a look and can
give each other yeah III aneesa's asking
can we ever like read each other's
facial expressions or body language that
before even like saying you're really
implying anything I think we can John
can tell when I'm mad or upset or hyper
focus yeah and that gets Owen Jon's
feeling
confident arouse session we start
touching himself in the office let's try
to keep it quiet but you know the finger
so apprentice headed workers Jojo rabbit
reaction that's the first time that's
happened
what Jojo rabbit JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure the first time that makes up
as legitimately happen cuz I keep
expecting it doing it though I mix it up
all the time in my brain okay I like it
always makes me think of it but Marie I
hear a Dinesh
thank you for your super tread Dinesh
please react to votes and that's not
that's not German about its own video so
I know it's I will keep that in I will
keep that in mind right here is the Nash
thank you buddy do my best to find it
and Erik Hersman my dude Erik with the
stealth mode in here
he just contributed a $50 super chat
with not even a question about you know
there's not even a sticker here no
nothing just just cold hard cash ooh
what did we miss something here that is
just not popping up in the chats hold on
I gotta find it you contributed a $50
super jacket Yuri another $10 superfan
saying freaking forgot about the stream
freaking whiskey that I want a classic
Erik horseman type of super chatty it'll
be my Eric horseman intensive thank you
for doing that
please be safe Erik watch the alcohol
just a little bit just take care of your
liver that's all we ask
really appreciate that Erik
III I know you caught the last page of
the day shot we did for I think I really
loved that one that was a funny one no
memory me laugh I see a Greek flag in
the chat
maybe we should grease that's cool
let's see what else do we got here cabin
fever - yeah that would be awkward
we haven't even one would be awkward emo
Wolfgang's asking the live stream yeah
we were acted to a screaming on video
about a couple weeks ago not that often
enough
Jasmine you're amazing Thank You Jasmine
would be nice pitch meeting reactions
did better those are so thin divide well
yeah that's right Alex Jones is gonna
eat his neighbor's I heard about that
crazy Alex 18 once Greg to notice him I
have noticed you dude
senpai look out Wow okay okay we've done
that part of the livestream where we're
just reading everything Wow interesting
conversations happening in the light oh
man sorry about that
Greg's watched a little Clone Wars and a
scene from I've been watching some clone
oh yeah yeah free I mentioned that been
watching some Clone Wars recently I've
been watching in chronological order you
see now I know why I fell off the show
because I started watching it in the
release date order and I didn't I
couldn't quite get it and then watching
a chronological or I'm like I was way
more engaging I'm always fascinated by
when they air things literally out of
chronology shows will do that it's
sometimes very apparent
alright I'm trying to catch up here so
we can start showing people super chests
on screen Andre doesn't know thank you
for your super chat dude French girls
for a movie they regret watching your
family French girls seen Titanic with
his mom I was okay okay good good
because earlier in this livestream I
brought up how I thought it was funny
how Titanic being at like a 2 billion
dollar box-office return mega hit that
families definitely watch seem to let it
slide that you see some boobage action
in the movie right yeah with their kids
it's like they're just like alright kids
the one time you could watch boobs it
was [ __ ] Titanic for support it's
beautiful
okay Andre doesn't know yeah thanks for
super Jeff French girls seen tights hang
my mom I was so freaked out up for
watching and that steamy car scene I
don't think I would get through it now
really now you don't we'll wait I'm kind
of confused by this are the so freaked
out after watching that
Oh with your mom okay so he's
traumatized from the experience of
watching that with your mom I'm so I'm
wondering like are there other families
out there who experience that dislike
strange uncomfortableness with Titanic
but no one's talked about that yeah like
how much of them that might have been a
very uncomfortable experience with your
mom I bet that's probably yeah but
that's I bet that's a memory that's
buried in a lot of people's subconscious
is the awkwardness of their first
Titanic viewing oh my thank you okay
before streaming we are set we stream
this off stream you are seeing one
action movie Anatomy does but are seems
to bug out a lot more than their go we
we've got up to a caught up point you
shoot their tech guy a message would be
like how do you make this thing sing so
well
Erik horseman Anissa álava
is saying where's doc D'Arnot Donna
Cabot she said now that Eric horseman is
in okay here's the ongoing fee that's
happening in case you guys know Eric
horseman and Anissa are our top
contributors for the real rejects when
you can buy like livestream patreon and
so now there's a weird competition
happening with Denis is saying in there
thank you for the superjet Anissa Eric
my number one competitor for number one
fan by the way guys love the last shout
out very interesting of how Eric and I
first met I did a shout out for them I
wrote it upwards as if they were the
first time they met each other oh and
then Eric is back here and he's saying
very interesting Anissa
I just face it we need a real rejects
con and we can all meet after covered of
course even though my state of Georgia
is acting like its back back to [ __ ]
normal
oh is Georgia going back to Georgia is
open I think we're just open my friend
lives in
see Tennessee's open the first day they
opened up there was a tornado I don't
think it was as bad as there's a contact
there that's kind of fun
I don't think it was quite as bad as the
one like a month ago all right
Erika Denise you don't have to fight in
this live stream okay just get a log
don't need to have a super chat
competition I mean whoever wins the best
Dave but thank you Eric for your and
Anissa for the consistent contributions
you have been making throughout our
lives thank you here mmm where aren't we
at here guys we are at the two-hour mark
and nine seconds wow that was almost
exact Congrats who's been show of hands
wonder people speaking in like French or
Spanish in here okay that's our educated
ire I mean why are you commenting zagnut
because that's one of my favorite
candies I got a question for you guys
are you guys gonna watch Scoob it's
coming out on demand next week is that
something we should review are you guys
do Scooby Doo sure we're reviewing Scoob
all right
oh I feel like we should be caught up by
this point yeah just got scroll slow all
right and don't scroll past
okay the Eric and Anissa wars are
continuing thank you it needs to for
your super jet to now they're having a
conversation with them yes Eric let's
plan to reject Khan that would be
amazing if there was a reject Khan I'm
letting you know it would just be you to
show which reporting well you know what
maybe we could do a double toast to
dinner this team up who's the r-tx
roosterteeth condoms we'll all do a con
and
together and then we'll pretend that all
those people didn't show up for double
dose in roosterteeth totally down same
here Texas thinking it's back to normal
as well it's not as far as man we have a
friend Andrew Terpening who just had a
baby in Texas and left the baby here
he's in a bunker somewhere no yeah that
says nuts that some states are just like
willy nilly [ __ ] like yes compared to
seven billion humans maybe you could
argue some of the numbers of smugly the
you can't control a germ in the air so
your chances are chances anyway well I
can't tell if you know this seems to be
I can't tell people want us to watch
Scoob or not Aneesa thank you for your
contribution again but you know do you
guys can just actually talk I appreciate
it
maybe we could do a community post to
see if people want to have a scoop
review alright guys we're gonna wrap
this up shortly funny games is not a
movie you want to watch with your family
we're gonna wrap this up shortly but are
you making sure reading everything it's
in French do you remember the time when
we watch 20 games
yeah we saw funny yeah you know we
wanted like a highlight memorable
experience or something I just watched
the movies but wasn't it like after we
had a big fight it was like the night we
had a big fight and then I came over to
Denise's house we worked and we watched
funny he's like pre-youtube
yeah this is like way before I was
cooking hot dogs yeah yeah yeah we were
having like a really heated text back
and forth and then you came over
funny guys oh yeah there was a memory
associated with that more emotional yeah
how far things like I don't know if
we're gonna watch scoop or not I'm going
off of the ten people who are actually
answering the question five that's 10
views you can take to the bank
Cedric say knock knock hey Rizzo gaming
I'm glad you're here you [ __ ] me if
you have you guys seen knock-knock I'm
good your dog Keanu Reeves director hey
lai Roth you can imagine the kind of
but but but like lorenza izzo and anna
de armas have both gone on to do like a
bunch you know like like anna de armas
was the star of knives out and learns is
owes and once upon a time hollywood not
like you know it's fun about going to
your guys's that this live stream is so
many you got i the reason my head is
over here a lot is because this i've you
the live stream here and there's a
little space so many things of you guys
mentioning specifics of the scenes that
your comments are getting blocked
they're not being shown that's not my
doing that's youtube automatic in right
now with a colleen Underwood hello that
you and your comments keep getting
blocked just because of the topics in
your and your messages yeah so i keep
having a hit show to a lot of your
comments too because like so many this
keeps happening so i love it don't
censor yourselves guys I like Eric why
do you look like stephen malkmus that's
a that's the reference to make yeah
apparently you make a music Eric hey
call call Colton Colleen Colton
Underwood Colton happy early birthday to
you buddy and John I was asking you is
what scene is what movie or show is
there where people do it in a
confessional booth and me me am with her
super Jenna said yes seen in fleabag
hashtag hot priests yeah Andrew Scott
man he's really tearing it up right now
what is it like sex with a priest yeah I
guess so I'm assuming base I haven't
seen all of it but I feel like yeah I
remember some kind of confessional sex
scene
damn yeah I love like those that
storyline and shows and movie like the
first season and Sopranos there's a
priest who wants to do with Tony
Soprano's wife Oh bad idea
yeah just like dude like if you're if
you're a priest in yer and you're
getting into that like with yeah I don't
even try not that I know how that
concludes and Sopranos but I have to
imagine not
Elfi priest hey I want to ask you guys
to you guys seen Jerry Seinfeld's
newsstand oh special is that any good on
Netflix Canada gang what's a Canada gang
like I want to know my friend I have
some friends who live in Canada and one
of them hi Lyndsey if you ever see this
sends me Canadian graffiti and I really
love Canadian graffiti it's it's very
charming hey there are some people here
who have been in our live stream since
like the moment we started and I want to
thank all you like just I've like just
to name a couple Giselle and Cedric and
oh where is he where's the name I'm
sorry the lobsters going to little ifs
there's a nice of course there's a lot
of you guys who have been here for a
long time in the past few hours so thank
you for being here for so long well we
fancy you two good boys would be an
uncomfortable to watch your fan for sure
yeah
good news I haven't seen you imagine it
would be just like watching super bad
but with you people and it's Owen ISA
thank you so much thank you this is
whenever we're about to wrap up a live
stream when it's come nearing the end of
it and he says always go on coming here
with a full force also I encourage you
all Greg and John for someone in the
health profession please don't get the
vaccination if they come out with one it
has not been tested up to give out to
people but I know it's going to happen
soon okay I appreciate the heads-up
that's a good thing to know yeah maybe
that's a good thing for all of you guys
Anissa works in the ER so I'm gonna take
her opinion on it cuz she would get the
down-low on these kind of things so
thank you and ISA that's free she's
getting the word out there yeah and then
it makes me wonder what the rules are
because I would feel like you would want
to make absolutely sure that that's a
good idea before putting it out to the
public
oh boy alright
Oh random Andy's channel back at it yes
I still believe in after marriage for me
I got a respect and keep what they toss
to believer for so many years of
teaching since mom passed way to honor
that dude respect and based off your
good-looking profile pic you should be
on your way to lining yourself a
significant other for the rest of your
life very soon you should be married
already
do it now mmm-hmm I can't wait for you
to get married and
you know get is John leaving if you want
to take my spot and just continue this
dream I'll leave sir whatever you want
it's your house we're gonna get we're
gonna order some posts mates they have a
have some free delivery deals going out
there right now oh and I've lost the
spot on the on the super chat sorry
about that
the real ones watch the whole thing of
the live streams appreciate that okay
where are we out here making sure
ricotta and dude okay
Anissa and Eric you guys are so crazy
Eric is saying thank you for your super
chat again Eric horseman he's saying
reject con on this must happen also pass
by AMC and parking lot empty so sad but
the state the [ __ ] home peeps unless an
essential shopping trip for alcohol so
only go outside if you need alcohol
according to Eric horseman and now this
may negate my next question but Eric
because I feel like you would know is
there an efficient way of getting
alcohol delivered to you I think there
is because without it costing like a
huge amount of shipping and then Aneesa
oh we gotta and this is saying yes Eric
we're going to plan recheck calm when
all of this is over it would be so great
ready to plan this I love planning stuff
I'm a little afraid this is actually
happening sometimes I love planning
stuff like this I'm like oh I hope you
guys actually do play Eric you're
drinking right now don't need to super
chat anymore buddy
appreciate it but you don't need to hate
Comic Cons going remote this year we
could do a remote Commission is a remote
convention right now is the reason this
is the remote communities yeah we just
need to grab your nametag and of course
always Eric is I'm glad you guys have
rileymadel be BFFs
Eric gonna tease the two top
contributors at the real rejects thank
you
oh there's gonna be a time where the
four of us are all hanging out together
it's gonna be great
guarantee it Gisele you look great so
don't worry about being 33 legendary
Deadeye thank you my friend do you think
Hollywood should put the new movies on
Netflix or a certain amount of time like
one week no I think it's fine just
postponing it honestly it's gonna work
itself out but our movies that cannot go
into production so a lot of movies that
have had a release dates planned have
not even shot anything at all so it's
all gonna it's all gonna line up
eventually we just got to be a little
patient and we just gotta wait and we'll
all go back to normal release dates
eventually all right enjoy that
anticipation yeah let's let let's keep
feeling that sizzle until the steak is
finally deliver to us I had a movie near
you I feel bad for like the people
behind trolls world tour and stuff like
that because you know they're getting a
lot of unfair flack for universals
decision but I the only thing I could
argue on behalf of it is like yeah if
it's I almost feel like if it's intended
for families it's a decent time to do
that because you know families are going
to be at home and that makes some sense
to me but yeah most most releases I
think they ought to just hold on to now
you know one day Daniel Jones you're
right by the way legendary did I thank
you for your super chat buddy thank you
know one day won't just be the four of
us there'll be a whole giant
meet-and-greet in the UK Daniel Jones
there'll be it's so many of us be fun to
do a meet I've never done an actual like
never held like we're going into town
let's do an official meeting great be
fun and do that I'm so worried I was
gonna show up like five people these
shows all I care pick a random Saturday
night just be like hey meet us at this
movie theater we're gonna watch this
thing this is not likely to sell out so
we can all buy our own ticket
of course you can Aneesa John is looking
for a roommate you can mujer with John
comes here don't have to always do it at
the gas station and he said plus it's a
good time to move I love the
I love this oh yeah I look okay thank
you you guys don't have to keep super
chatty
seriously it's you don't have to turn
active but I'm glad you two are like
getting this is so nice you two get
along like this is reward firing this is
really Rory you two have found
friendship it's and it's fun going to
like the the super chat it's not going
to like the regular the livestream
challenges seen how you guys are talking
with each other too it's it's so cool
seeing people interact or subscribers of
us thank you
oh well and aneisa and and eric so glad
you two are getting along so well it's
great what color do you think about when
you think of Olivia Mme King goodbye I
am ma Olivia what color do you think
about when you think about me I think
about oh my god a Suns hell no no no of
the blue color that you it's the blue
color
no their favorite color oh my god why is
not coming to mind right now I'm drawing
up like any food is it a light blue or a
dark blue
John please I will kick you out of here
I think she you know probably earn you
points again wherever you need me I
shall go amber Jones you ready for the
meet-and-greet well then all right babe
what color do you think of when you
think of is that our in the live stream
where you come in here yes don't use the
new sponge why not do cosplay i'll do
cosplay I'm locked in though with this
hair oh no don't I don't want to be
single no guys this is so tragic what
color do you think of when you think of
me oh what's the blue you love I should
know what blue you love I'm sorry people
want to say hi to you they're all saying
and want you to come in
thank you guys always break every week
Tiffany's blue Tiffany's blue is your
favorite I have a whole list of facts
about you in my phone have a source or a
caller from man look people love you
Olivia they do you're always the
highlight you guys have been great in
this stream baby show your face show
your [ __ ] beautiful face what are you
doing yeah don't be like this she has
shown me three seasons of The Sopranos
now man okay when I think of John I
think of a dark abyss black actually no
well I won't say that I think of myself
as those colors I'll give them to you as
accurate oh babe I have a question for
you the live stream theme today is
movies you regret watching with your
family is there any ones that come to
mind for you that we're very comfortable
you watched I don't know what was it
scary movie oh I saw that two of my
family that was so uncomfortable there's
a lot of hands over eyes is like a very
my dad would just say that's satanic
that is satanic Devils work it is the
devil's business thanks babe Oh Rizzo
gaming Ryan beta zero six six thanks
buddy I would say the Thomas Crown
Affair
with Pierce Brosnan and Thor's mom Rene
Russo that's a lot of nudity and a
sexiness that was a weird experience
yeah yeah I saw that with my family too
you know that's the thing there was a
time where they didn't give you heads up
in the r-rated what it was weighted are
four and sure enough crazy ass sex scene
in that movie like they're like pouring
champagne or Renee Russo's nipples in
that film that see I'm always surprised
when they do stuff like that movies
things that are like specifically erotic
yeah were we out here and we got Ryan
baby oh people are saying they would
like a reject Kahn meet up in the UK
it'd be cool you know what I'm thinking
I'm thinking of going to India saying
Jabby Co is here in India and then see
who falls for it and doesn't realize I'm
not Jabba cool I'll come as a charm I'll
just shave my beard off and see if that
works
hey Anna Chara Kurtz birthday's tomorrow
by the way thank you for being here Ryan
Beatty 0 6 6 6 up fell behind on the
stream again alright it's okay we'll
catch bow here we are hard nipple thank
you hard nippy's I like I like that
because I'm always about my nippy chills
thank you that's the guy who plays Chiti
right or is that you
is this from midsummer that actually
looks like that actor I don't know I saw
good boys in my parents a worse
experience in my life I'm sorry they
made me feel like a bad boy yeah that's
the kind of comedy you get at for two
hours and 20 minutes if you laugh at
these jokes you're a bad boy yourself is
I've also realized too we do these live
streams after already doing a full day
of shooting and editing for other things
and then we do these like long as Liars
like John can't because I'm like well
John can't be mainly does the live
stream awaken appease may I can a good
any type of those vulgar raunchy
comedies with family members which is
made me wildly uncomfortable so I can
identify with you man
copper has successfully tackled my
backpack what do you mean he's so was
the cat in this try to knock that thing
over Mister Donut Studios thank you for
a super chat buddy oh my [ __ ] what we
love you too you Kevin Smith look-alike
just a nap away the quarantine can you
snap the waves of the pandemic oh you're
so stinky Mister Donut studios man who
can take your spot John
no one can dance I burped he's next door
I think Manisa also have your package
almost ready to try to get everything to
get here before John's birthday so
hopefully it does also John double check
on your birthday again I'm pretty sure I
have it correct John's birthday is June
12th is it what's coming out on June
12th there's something coming out on
June 12th
I don't remember now that's supposed to
be were making a joke about it being
really exciting John's birthday June
12th guys so keep a lookout well are
excited for the package Aneesa make sure
to get John something good I think it's
gonna be lingerie photos of Annie so for
you
oh this that's what I asked for yeah not
in that poll I just asked kind of [ __ ]
that's gonna get you canceled I asked my
mom for them you asked your mom for
lingerie photos of your mom no of
venice' Aneesa I didn't even talk about
it your joke doesn't make any sense
super Jess to get a mailbox by then I
feel like you can get a mailbox right
now so I'm gonna see if I can do that
tomorrow wrote on it's almost 8 p.m. for
us right here all right get get copper
out of here Oh Cedric you're so sweet
it's
it's so fun to just kind of go there's
only use obs as I can have your guys's
livestream on display too it's so fun to
just like get lost in the the stream
where I forget there's a camera and
we're live and we're being recorded
I just start reading everything
everyone's saying I don't know you guys
got to talk to her Nisa yeah she is the
queen of this like Rosa Park of our
channel the anisa is like the the queen
of our livestream yeah she really is
yeah Ethan Holgate says every Will
Ferrell movie wasn't comfortable to
watch with his family Oh even everything
must go
Jacob is asking water next livestream
about I'm not sure what our next live
should be about I usually just come up
with them on the spot like before I make
an announcement I usually run like I got
one or two solid ideas by John that run
by John really quick it was I believe
Artemis Fowl was this was supposed to
come out on my birthday
Peter Pacheco is saying thank you Peter
Pacheco for your super chat Batman or
Robin and you know Portuguese yet I'll
learn it Peppa Chad no don't John you're
supposed to why I am even Portuguese I'm
on duolingo so I'll get back to you in a
few years Batman or Robin was the movie
you regret watching with your family
wasn't it that was so bad it was it just
like it's such an uncle like do you
regret watching the movie or is it the
what is there something significant that
happened in the boys and I yeah poison
ivy just too attractive of a character
that was to grossly or do you just
regret spending the Sun were we out here
has been hotel and who's the boss
I saw shout out flow shows if you
haven't seen has been hotel I go I still
gotta watch uh uh was it the boss one
but yeah go watch has been hotel eric
horseman
no need a super chat anymore appreciate
it buddy would please it's ok they're
really sweet thank you
absolutely I get all my alkie he gets
all's alcohol I'm but who the [ __ ]
musician I look like Google a guy I know
his name and vaguely the kind of music
he makes but I can't really tell you got
like that or a Jeffrey Dahmer look one
of the two you know what your profile
pic always makes me think of the misfits
I just think in the long black but uh
where do you get your alcohol online
Eric just tell me don't you tell I was
how many love to hang I can't wait the
day I hang out with you a person Eric
seriously that's I've become real
rejects hatchets I don't think it will
truly hit all the way until we actually
are with him in person and then I'm
gonna kill you Eric and I'm gonna carve
that patch off of your arm and then so
that piece of skin that you have on your
the tattoo onto my arm oh my god and you
know what you're gonna get off on it as
a dead guy Thank You mr. doughnut
studios thank you buddy okay here's an
idea I'll set up a meeting here in San
Jose California right when COBIT is done
BAM
really see I have more faith in someone
else setting up a meet and greet for us
because then they will probably talk
with other subscribers or other fans
there's a tangibility because the second
I'm like I'm gonna set up a meet and
greet here's what happens of my brain
this is what I have for so many years
I've never done it it goes up in my
brain is no one's gonna show you think
people really want to you and I put this
energy out there and then I'm just like
I know what that energy I'm putting out
there that means no one's gonna show
because my energies that strong so
that's why I haven't done it but if you
want to do it and then we see that
there's people who are willing to show
up and hell yeah that'd be great thank
you dude I'm so hungry guys hungry by
Giselle Oh 21 Jump Street
that's a scooter looters saying 21 gem
with the family a lot of people are
saying the raunchy comedies man yeah
yeah sex jokes and family man amber why
are you jealous of Eric horseman there's
no need to be that's right the king of
Staten Island is also a June release on
my bday still gotta watch that trailer
olivia is salty and tasty oh my gosh
sure is oh it's what I love about her
actually I shouldn't be agreeing with
you
thanks for the superjet Aneesa John John
and he says a question for you what
color do you think of when you think of
Aneesa the real question it's a
combination either
it's scrub that you know that that pale
scrubs blue or else it's that color I
don't know the name of that's like when
you see a sunset and it's like not quite
pink but not quite orange it's like
somewhere in the middle that's that's
where I put you oh that's so sweetie you
John thanks man
you're like assure you know what I'm a
greenish go ahead I was I having I know
you're talking about Lisa but I'm just
like I don't really care and let's talk
about me you're a lot of colors to me
nearly 4 a.m. Daniel thank you for
keeping ago you just had a birthday
thank you Andy so that's so sweet of you
I mean look if you want to just give us
a sincere thank you you don't have to
pretend I mean we really appreciate it
but okay would you say okay sincere
thank you here I know I'd say you think
o-town show meaning maybe I'll truly
mean the world I'm not close to many
people my family and I mean that's kind
of [ __ ] awkward to say you live with
your family with the people of my home
as I'm saying this out loud and typing
it out loud they're listening to me and
looking at me all brown my day and I
don't feel there's no reason to feel
alone from impression I gather from your
family at the phone your work
environment sounds like you're a very
loved individual and just from getting
to know you you're very easy to like
individual keep in mind I've grown to
know I've gotten to know you way before
we started doing these live strange
consistently so I'm not just speaking
from the fact that you've been such a
major
contributor to our live streams I'm
speaking from the place of the person I
knew before we started doing these live
streets and from that in this position
before people sort of thing we're just
saying this because of the superjet and
that's not true I've never for many
months before all this so Aneesa you've
been incredibly sweet thank you so much
and you know you don't need a show
thanks by doing like upping the
contributions you make on these super
jazz I really appreciate it though
you're very sweet
and you're gonna make Olivia very happy
place and midsummer I gotta learn that
guy's name he's a good actor
Olivia does not like Olivia does not
like Will Ferrell that's it's true it's
one thing my mom and Olivia have in
common
Oh somebody wants us to put our
convention up with one of the
supernatural conventions I would love
that
that'd be fun then we could react to the
supernatural convention watching them
talk about what was the influence their
influence oh we got another one here
from Ryan Beatty
also watch True Lies with my
grandparents so that jay'll see the
seduction scene was an experience love
you guys all these rooms are well worth
no sleep well buddy I think it's
important you get some sleep we got a
doctor see one thing about rizzo gaming
aka Ryan Beatty on our patreon we do
reactions to Doctor Who and at the
beginning of each one of our Doctor Who
reactions we read off fun facts that
Ryan Beatty personally sent us about the
prior episode so he's been great over
there and you oh my god the true lysine
dad I saw that movie in school in Flynn
school and and yeah I mean whoo I heard
that seems become problematic I haven't
seen it since people started declaring
it as problematic yeah I haven't either
I would be curious as I don't remember
all of the context
what's the what's which is she's
seducing Arnold where's the bill paxton
no she doesn't know that's Arnold she's
dancing for someone but she thinks she
has to do it or else they'll release
some information about her but Arnold's
the one manip that's why it's [ __ ] the
context of that scene was well this is
what it's bad either away but it's
almost well if I got there on my own of
how that's a [ __ ] because no because
it's easy to remember that scene and go
yeah you know the the Jamie Lee Curtis
dance and forget what the scenes about
you know people are asking me if I know
get Jabby
I'm gonna do something fun for you guys
before we end this dream oh I'm not
ready this is authentic - I'm watchfully
he answers hopefully he answers I hope
he has one of those answering machine
calling Jabby co-heir right now it just
says his phone number love jab eco I'm
on a live stream right now I love
catching you off guard I have one
question for you is there any is there
any movie the theme today his movies you
regret watching with your family and
I've named a ton was there any movie you
regret watching that may was an
uncomfortable experience with mom or dad
or you see the room the theme of this
stem today because I was thinking about
how it's Mother's Day tomorrow and I was
like I've had so many awkward with mom
like I saw Brokeback Mountain with her
in the
I didn't know it was gonna be like a
hardcore but it would be a friendly man
all right thank you and someone with it
was like a research but anyway we got
some people in the chat who still don't
know we're brothers so I wanted to just
call you to prove it you're a pawn
that's how shabby this hears the sound
of his pan all right well unsub when
they hear your breath well I will chat
with you tomorrow thank you for
everything
bye-bye love you hahaha I got him he
didn't say it this time no proof
otherwise I have seen the HBO Lovecraft
County trailer already country trailer
those are cool all right I really react
to it because of all the music in it and
would have really yeah
Eric horseman hi Olivia you are amazing
on subject made the mistake of watching
crews with the big Al Pacino watch Oh
cruising either talking about Tom look
what Tom Cruise Al Pacino movie no with
her totally had a boner owner crazy with
who your mom yeah just guess the Eric
must have watched that with family
that's it that's it actually yeah I
don't hate that movie it's a weird
[ __ ] movie but I don't hate that
movie I love how you said you got a
boner you know the movies about you guys
are cruising is about it's an Al Pacino
movie
I forgot what movie that director some
other really popular film
80s and it's about Al Pacino is an
undercover cop pretending to be and
going under the gay community and it's
like being gays bad and there's a serial
killer presumably homosexual who's
killing off other homosexuals so Al
Pacino's posing undercover as a gay gay
guy but then he's he's being torn
because maybe he is a [ __ ] strange
move it's cool thank you Eric by the way
that's a good category oh the l word
that would not be a family watch no I
would not if you guys can meet up at the
next UK Comic Con would you of course
actually yeah to be totally honest the
most time I have ever gotten recognized
in my entire life was when I went to
comic-con I was like oh I've never been
recognized so much and like don't worry
we'll wrap this up in just a minute
Eric horseman thank you again buddy let
this be the last one error yes what
color do you think of me just had asked
thanks to me sup Eric the color I think
of you is bright sunshiny yellow my
color would be a relative of that I'll
just go the the moon side which is you
know like an Amber sort of smoky whiskey
color so you know just darken that
yellow way down Anissa thank you Eric
and he's the st. John the color I think
of when I think of you is probably a
blush pink because that's a make me feel
so for being so cheesy if I wasn't so
white and blown out on this camera right
now I would be blushing too I would say
that the color you make Anissa feel is
what pink I acknowledge your comment and
appreciate you giving me sound to work
bye Ginny hi the last couple ones here
we go in the homestretch Thank You Annie
Sud John read it John
you touched my heart melted it
completely and there's an
oh gee that I think is not carrying here
I'm happy to hear that I meant it that
was for you happy after birthday no
compliments to me Aneesa Wow
tip again no no no no no we need to get
you home get you home we got a busy week
coming this coming week
yeah we're brothers everyone make sure
to wish Achara happy birthday by the way
Charlotte Outlander and altered carbon
with car mother dad jeepers
I didn't realize Outlander had some of
the edginess that it did I knew it was
like steamy but Rizzo gaming Brian
Beatty not a movie but watch the first
episodes of sense8 with family that
shows a lot of sex orgies Mike let's say
I watch the rest by myself with the door
locked
ooh now wanna watch sensei yeah knowing
which house key style sex orgy yeah be
weird it's weird because like I'm not
surprised to hear that for some reason
maybe maybe it's just because a bound or
something like that and yeah that like
the rave and the sexiness of matrices a
certain amount of like sexuality with
what they make but uh Wow [ __ ] you saw
me on that show now thank you
thanks Ryan Beatty hey man a lot of
people really bummed to see it go and
we're hoping that you know it would get
revived somewhere guys um oh man I'm so
excited for Mother's Day tomorrow I
cannot wait I need to go get something
because like javi Kawai and my
girlfriend Olivia like as Olivia loves
to challenge Jabby
and it's always fun cuz I'm laughing and
sometimes javi can't tell if if she's
just [ __ ] with him or if she's being
serious and that's what just cracks me
if your brother's Jabby drunk is the
best Jabby drunken zabi drop is the best
most gregarious sociable and filled with
advice guy
pretty cool too but Jabby drunk is the
best it needs to give you a color Greg
the color think of when I think you as a
four screen like I'm in Colorado
oh hell yeah thank you all right guys
well thank you guys so much for being
here appreciate everyone to contribute
to the super chat really appreciate this
was fun this was fine I thought this
livestream was a great balance of
keeping it chill keeping the energy here
I'm reviewing our livestream what a
weird thing to do at the end of a
livestream you know the took a little
time to get going but really wants it he
you know hits try breaking act too it's
great I appreciate everyone could choose
these super chats and I just appreciate
everyone who's been here in the comments
and and talking with us don't feel bad
if you didn't get a chance to do a super
chat totally understand if you're unable
to being here no reason to feel bad at
all anyone who's saying that thank you
guys so much and oh my god Jesus Christ
love Jesus Christ I'll feel really bad
about ologist I can't wait to go to LA
to meet you Anisa I can't wait to go to
Texas to meet you then John to pump you
with the gas station and Ryan Beatty
thank you so much the what color reminds
you of me
hop out on this I would say the color
would be green for the TARDIS
green illumination in the Doctor Who
show that's a good one actually I was
for whatever reason I thought of a very
Sun spotty orange red thanks amber Jones
you rock burnt orange for gray love all
you guys thank you everyone who's been
here since the early parts of the of the
livestream everyone's been amazing to us
thank you
combing my hair on the air with Michael
where John thought of that two hours ago
as a way to say it the entire time no
somebody literally just requested so I
did and uh yeah Anissa thank you for
reminding me happy Mother's Day to
everyone's happy and happy happy
Mother's Day
love you my cat wants me to go in there
and yeah one day we'll all do a meet up
thank you a nice happy Mother's Day to
everyone have a good time with your
family I'm not able to be
with your mom be with someone's mom